من قهرمان مرعش ينضم الينا غسان ابو لوز
مفيد العربيه اهلا بك معنا غسان اذا هناك
رغم مرور هذه الايام وهذه الساعات هناك ما
زال امل بوجود احياء تحت الانقاذ خصوصا
وانه بالفعل في الساعات الماضيه تم العثور
على عدد من الاحياء كيف تسير الامور الان
لديك
نعم بالفعل فاطمه كما ذكرتي مازال هناك
امل
بانتشال احياء من تحت الانقاذ وما زالت
عمليات الانقاذ ورفع الانقاذ مستمره حتى
هذه اللحظه كما ذكرت نحن في كهرمان مرعش
يعني مركز الزلزال في جنوب البلاد وهي
متضرره جدا وبلده منكوبه
تعاني جدا نتيجه هذا الزلزال وكما تشاهدين
خلفي من الصوره سنضع الكاميرا تريكم
المشاهد في هذا الحي كم حجم الدمار الهائل
الذي لحق بهذا الحي نتيجه الزلزال وما زال
عمال الانقاذ كما تشاهدين بالصوره يحاولون
الوصول الى
عالقين تحت الانقاذ سمعنا من يعني
شهود عيان هنا ان هناك
ناجينا في هذه المناطق حيث يعملون الان
تحت هذه الانقاذ يعني ما زالت الامال
موجوده بوجود ناجين ما زال هناك يعني
اشخاص يخرجون على قيد الحياه بعد اكثر من
عشرين ساعه تم انقاذهم وتتواصل هذه
العمليات حتى هذه اللحظه رغم تضاءل فرص
النجاه بعد يعني مرور سته ايام فاطمه من
الزلزال الذي ضرب هذه البلاد طبعا هذه
بلده منكوبه هذه الاحياء التي تشاهدينها
بالصوره الان لا يوجد فيها اي احد من
السكان تم اخلاء واجلاء سكان هذه المدينه
بسبب الزلزال الذي ضربها وبسبب يعني خطوره
العوده الى هذه المنازل وايضا لا توجد
مظاهر للحياه اصلا هنا بسبب هذه بسبب هذا
الدمار الكامل طبعا الكهرباء مقطوعه عن
هذه المنطقه والمياه مقطوعه عن هذه
المنطقه وما زال العمل مستمر حتى هذه
اللحظه ولك ان تتخيل حجم الاطنان فاطمه في
منطقه كهرمان مرعش ويعني حجم الجهد
المبذول من فرق الانقاذ وجميع المؤسسات
يعني الدوله والمؤسسات المدنيه وايضا
الفرق الاجنبيه التي تقدم مساعداتها
الاتراك هنا طبعا تحدث تحدثت السلطات عن
اجلاء اكثر من 190 الف الى مناطق امنه كما
تحدثت عن نصب اكثر من 180 خيمه ومنزل مؤقت
في يعني مناطق امنه لاستيعاب
المتضررين وايضا تقول انهم يعني قدموا
مراكز ايواء مؤقته لاكثر من مليون شخص
العمليات ما زالت مستمره في كهرمان منع
مرعش وفي مناطق اخرى يعني هناك مناطق تم
الاعلان عن انتهاء عمليات الانقاذ
وبالتالي توجهت تلك الفرق الموجوده في تلك
المناطق الى مناطق اخرى كما كهرمان مرعش
وايضا مناطق اخرى يعني بحاجه للاسناد
والمساعده في عمليات الانقاذ ورفع الانقاذ
يعني ما زال هناك الامل قائم لدى الباحثين
عن احياء تحت الانقاض غسان هناك انباء
تتحدث عن فتح الفنادق لايواء المتضررين
والذين فقدوا منازلهم كذلك هل بالفعل تم
ذلك الان هل الخيام كافيه هل الاماكن
الايواء حتى الان كافيه
العدد كبير فاطمه عدد المتضررين كبير جدا
يعني كما تحدث تحدثت السلطات هنا ان اكثر
من 13 مليون شخص تضرروا في المناطق
الجنوبيه وفي الولايات العشر نتيجه هذا
الزلزال وبالتالي نعم بالفعل هناك يعني
تفاهمات وهناك تنسيق بين الحكومه وبين
القطاع الفندقي لاستقبال المتضررين في
القطاع الفندقي وايضا هناك الخيام ومراكز
الايواء لكن العدد كبير وبالتالي يتم
اجلاء هؤلاء الى مناطق اخرى مثل اسطنبول
وانقره
مناطق اخرى
لاستيعاب هذه الاعداد وما زالت عمليات
الاجلاء مستمره
وبطبيعه الحال فاطمه يعني حتى وان كانت
الخيام كافيه او المنازل المؤقته كافيه
هناك ظروف اخرى تفرض نفسها على هؤلاء
المتضررين بسبب الظروف الجويه وبسبب بروده
الطقس يعني درجه الحراره تصل الى مادون
صفر في الليل وبالتالي هم بحاجه الى
التدفئه وبحاجه الى الاغطيه الاغطيه وهي
تحديات كبيره تواجه السلطات وتواجه ايضا
المتضررين الذين يبيتون لياليهم في هذه
الخيام حتى ان بعض الناس
يلجاون الى سياراتهم الخاصه للمبيت في
داخلها نتيجه تضرر مساكنهم او حتى اولئك
الذين لم تتضرروا مساكنهم فيلجاون الى
السيارات خوفا من الهزات الارتداديه ووقوع
يعني
انهيارات في المباني خصوصا تلك المتصدعه
والايده للسقوط هناك يعني بالحديث عن
الهزات الارتداديه هل هناك انباء عن
المزيد منها هل توقفت لفتره ما
ما زالت السلطات تسجل فاطمه المزيد من
الهزات الارتداديه المئات من الهزات
الارتدائيه حتى الارتداديه حتى يوم امس تم
تسجيل اكثر من الف هزه ارتداديه وهي
بالتالي تشكل خطر كبير خصوصا على فرق
الانقاذ الموجوده في هذه المواقع هناك
مباني ما زالت صامده لكنها ايله للسقوط
بايه لحظه وبالتالي اي هزه ارتداديه ممكن
ان تؤدي الى كارثه جديده وتعقد من يعني
الازمه وهذا خطر يعني ما زال موجود وقائم
دائما الفرق الانقاذ والسلطات هنا تحذرنا
وتحذر اي شخص موجود في هذه المناطق من
الاقتراب من المباني لانها قد تسقط في اي
لحظه لا ادري الزميل يشير لي هنا بان هناك
تم انقاذ شخصين على تم انقاذ شخصين يقولوا
لهم ابلغونا الان انهم تم انقاذ شخصين هل
نستطيع ان نرى بالكاميرا الصحيه على ايه
حال
لا ادري ان كنا نستطيع ان نرصدهم
بالكاميرا على ايه حال فاطمه في هذه
الحاله يتم اجلائهم سريعا بسيارات الاسعاف
في سيارات الاسعاف ونقلهم الى اقرب مستشفى
لتقديم العلاج اللازم فاطمه لكن ان صحت
هذه الانباء ان هناك شخصين تم انتشالهم
فهذه انباء يعني جيده وانباء مفرحه
تقتربون من المكان هناك غسان ام ام ليس
بامكانكم الاقتراب اكثر
يعني سنحاول سنحاول الاقتراب الى ذلك
المكان لكن امنحين بعض الوقت يعني نعم
الان بدات السيارات او تتحرك على اي حال
فاطمه حسب ما فهمنا من
الاشخاص هنا ان سيارات الاسعاف التي تكون
بضوء اخضر تكون مخصصه للجثث اما السيارات
التي تقوم بضوء ازرق فهي تكون لاشخاص
ناجين وحالتهم الصحيه متوسطه اما اذا كان
اللون احمر
تكون
الحاله الصحيه لناجي لكنها خطيره وتستدعي
تدخل طبي سريع فبالتالي نحن نشاهد الان
الوان زرقاء لا ادري ان كان
وبصحه متوسطه
الان هم ابلغونا ونحن على الهواء معكم ان
هناك شخصين شخصين تم انتشالهم من تحته
الانقاذ وهم ناجين يعني لكن
لنشاهد كنا نستطيع ان نرصد هذه اللحظه
لحظه اخراجهم
ونتابع هذه الصور المباشره من كاميرا
العربيه في قهرمان مرعش على ما يبدو عمليه
انقاذ وانتشار لشخصين ما زالوا على قيد
الحياه ومفيد العربيه غسان سيؤكد لنا هذه
المعلومات
حال تمكنوا من ذلك هذه صور مباشره نتابعها
مع موفد العربيه غسان ابو لوز ومن كاميرا
العربيه كذلك لعمليات انقاذ تقام الان في
قهرمان مرعش في تركيا
ويبدو ان هناك عمليه انتشال لشخصين على ما
يبدو اضواء سيارات الاسعاف تضوي باللون
الازرق مما يعني كما ذكر غسان بانهم احياء
ولكن حالتهم الصحيه متوسطه ويجري الان
نقلهم الى المستشفى بشكل فوري لاسعافهم
والاطمئنان على حالتهم الصحيه
شخص واحد حتى الان
حتى الان حتى الان وشب سوري هو من الجنسيه
السوريه تم انقاذه
هكذا فهمنا يعني الانباء ما زالت غير
واضحه تماما تشاهدين ابتسامه يبدو انه
شقيقه او او سنحاول سنحاول التواصل معه
كمان ان شاء الله نعطيك في جميع الحمد لله
الحمد لله رب العالمين الحمد لله
وحده تسع سنين
يلا الحمد لله على السلامه الله يسلمك
يعني فاطمه يعني لا ادري ماذا اقول في هذه
اللحظات يعني واضح يعني
مشاعر الفرحه والصدمه والذهول يكد لا يصدق
هذا الوضع
غسان
ماذا تذكر هل قال انه هناك ثلاثه اشخاص تم
انقاذهم
تم انتشال فتاتين وبقيت الثالثه لكنهم
اكدوا له ان الثالثه على قيد الحياه
وبالتالي هم ينتظرون ان اخراج الفتاه
الثالثه من تحت الانقاذ لكنها
سنحاول ان ندخل الى الموقع
فاطمه لنشاهد كما تشاهدين فرق الانتقاد
مازلت موجوده وهناك ايضا جميع الادوات
اللازمه لهذه العمليات
اذا كم شخص حتى الان بالاسعار
فتاتين شخصين
واحده 11 سنه والثانيه تسع سنوات بقيت
ثالثه ما زالت الان تحت الانقاذ
يعني لم نعرف بصراحه ان كان والدهم ام لا
لكن يبدوا انه
والدهم او شقيقهم
كما تشاهدين الان بالصوره فاطمه ما زالت
تحاول فلك الانقاذ يعني الوصول الى الفتاه
الان فاطمه يطلبون منا الصمت ونحن يعني
الطريقه نعم
اذا نتابع معكم مشاهدينا صور مباشره من
قهرمان مرعش عبر شاشه الكاميرا لعمليه
انقاذ تم انتشار من خلالها فتاتين وتم
نقلهم الى الاسعاف مع الشخص على ما يبدو
انهم انه قريب لهم لا نعلم ان كان اباهم
ام اخاهم احد اقربائهم ولكن الان يبدو ان
هناك شخص ثالث
وتتم الان عمليه الصمت ليتمكنوا من سماع
اي صوت من تحت الانقاظ
انقاذ الاشخاص تحت لانهم يعني يذكر بان
هناك فتاتان تم انقاذهم الان ولكن هناك
ايضا شخص ثالث ينتظرينه تحت الانقاض على
امل ان يتمكنوا من انقاذ الشخص الثالث من
تحت الانقاظ اذا هناك صمت كامل فقط نعود
الى شخص نود ان نسالهم بناتك ام لا اختي
هذه اختي وجوزها واحده ماتوا ثلاثه تضلوا
هذول بنات اختك
البنت اللي ضلت كم عمرها اللي ضل يظل
عمرها سبع سنين او ثمانيه
شكرا شكرا
طلبوا منا المغادره
تعال شوي باسل سنعود الى عمليات الانقاذ
طبعا فاطمه كما تشاهدين ما زالت يعني
تتواصل الجهود للوصول الى الفتاه الثالثه
وكما علمنا انها عمرها سبع سنوات يعني
نستطيع ان نلاحظ ان هناك الحياه
نعم يعني حسب ما علمنا من خل البنات بانها
على قيد الحياه اكدوا له انها على قيد
الحياه وما زالوا حتى اللحظه يحاولون
الوصول اليها فاطمه هل انتهت لحظه الصمت
ما زالوا
انتهت لحظه الصمت فاطمه الان لن نسمع
اصوات المنقذين يتحدثون طلبوا قبل قليل
السكين المنقذين طلبوا سكين يبدو ان يعني
يحتاجون عليه قطع شيء ما في محاوله في
محاوله للوصول الى الطفله لا ادري ان كنا
نستطيع الاقتراب اكثر باسل سنحاول قدر
سنحاول الان فاطمه
الوصول اكثر الى المكان لكن يعني
نحن الان في اقرب نقطه فاطمه
لمحاوله انقاذ
الفتى الطفله المتبقيه وعمرها سبع سنوات
حسب ما فهمنا هي عائله
توفي احد الاشخاص منها
ثلاث بنات تم انقاذ والدتهم
من الشخص ان هناك شخص واحد توفى
يعني لم اذكر ماذا قاله للاسف لكن
هذا هو المشهد فاطمه في عموم جنوب البلاد
في تركيا في
كل المناطق المنكوبه
وتحديدا في كهرمان مع حيث نقف نحن الان
نعم
فاطمه
يتكرر هذا المشهد يوميا يوميا الاشخاص تحت
الانقاض يعني هل استخدموا الاجهزه
الحراريه او فقط استعانوا بالاصوات
كل شيء متاح فاطمه كل وسيله متاحه ويمكن
استخدامها يتم استخدامها رصدنا القوات
المسلحه التركيه تستخدم رادارا عسكريا
وهناك اجهزه استشعار متطوره وايضا هناك
كاميرات حراريه ايضا هناك الكلاب المتدربه
هاي الان يطلبون الكلب فاطمه باسل
يطلبون منا الصمت الان نطلبون من الصمت
وسنحترم ذلك بالتاكيد غسان نحن معك نتابع
هذه الصور المباشره عبر كاميرا العربيه في
قهرمان مرعش حيث يتم عمليه انقاذ وانتشار
لطفله تبلغ من العمر سبع سنوات عالقه تحت
الانقاض وتم قبل دقائق قليله انتشال
اختيها على ما يبدو تسع سنوات 11 سنه وتم
نقلهم بالاسعاف وكان معهم خالهم في
الاسعاف وكان يبدو عليه مشاعر السرور
ودموع السرور والفرح لاخراج الفتاتين
بانتظار اخراج ايضا اختهم البالغه من
العمر سبع سنوات على ما يبدو الان هم في
لحظه صمت ليتمكنوا من سمع اي صوت يصدر من
تحت الانقاض ونحن نتابع معكم لحظه بلحظه
هذه العمليه التي تتم في جنوب تركيا وهي
كما يذكر مفيدنا
مراسلينا عبر تركيا وسوريا عمليات انقاذ
مستمره في المناطق المنكوبه وهذه احد هذه
العمليات متابعه مباشره معكم عبر شاشه
العربيه
يبدو انهم
انتهوا من لحظه
الصمت على ما يبدو
غسان لا زالت مستم لا زالت مستمره
يترقبوا سماع اي صوت من تحت الانقاذ
لاحياء تم جلب كلاب للاستعانه فيهم وايضا
يستخدمون اجهزه حراريه الى جانب هذه
اللحظات الصمت لاستماع لاي اصوات تحت
الانقاض هناك فرق انقاذ عده في هذه
المنطقه
يبدو ان الفرق الانقاذ تتحدث وانتهت لحظه
الصمت ما الذي يجري غسان لم افهم
يهتفون باللغه التركيه او يحاولون ايصال
صوتهم للفتاه ان كانت تسمعهم حتى ترد
عليهم اذا على ما يبدو فرق الانقاذ في هذه
المنطقه وهذه او هذا المبنى تحديدا
يحاولون التواصل مع من هم تحت الانقاض
ليتمكنوا من سماعهم وايصال صوتهم لهم
لحظات الصمت مستمره ومحاولات
الانتشار اي احياء من صحه الانقاذ ما زالت
ايضا مستمره في الجنوب التركي فرق الالقاب
متواجده بشكل مكثف هذه فرق انقاذ تركيا
على ما يبدو التي نراها بالخوض الحمراء
على الشاشه
لعمليه انقاذ مباشره تحدث الان في هذه
اللحظات ونحن نتحدث عمليه انتشال وبحث
لمزيد من الاحياء تحت الانقاذ لانه قبل
دقائق قليله مشاهدينا وبعد اكثر من 122
ساعه من الزلزال لفجره الاثنين ما زال
هناك احياء تحت وما زال هناك امل
لايجاد المزيد من الاحياء
اجهزه واليات ومعدات كثيره متوفره
للاستعانه بها
يعني البحث عن الالقاء عن الاحياء تحت
الانقاذ من اجهزه حراريه
نعم هذه كل يعني كل كل ما هو متاح يتم
استخدامه في لمحاوله انقاذ ما يمكن انقاذه
سواء كان من اجهزه متطوره او كاميرات
حراريه او رادارات عسكريه ايضا الكلاب
المدربه نحن نشاهد الان
كلبان موجودان في هذا الموقع مع القوات
المسلحه التركيه وبالتالي اي شيء يمكن ان
يساعد في عمليات البحث لانقاذ العالقين
تحت الانقاض يستخدمون يتم توفير اي وسيله
وبما فيها هذه يعني الطريقه التي شاهدناها
قبل قليل ان هناك حالات الصمت التي
طلبوا منا ان نغادر الان هذا الموقع باسل
لا باس غسان طلبوا مني نحن
[موسيقى]
ويبدو ان سيارات الاسعاف التي تشير الى
انها يعني الاضواء الزرقاء تتجهز الان
فاطمه وذلك مؤشر جيد على ان
الطفله ما زالت على قيد الحياه نحن نحاول
يعني ان نفهم من المؤشرات الموجوده في
الموقع
يبدو انهم اقتربوا من انتشال هذه الطفله
ننتظر هذه اللحظه ننتظر هذه الولاده
الجديده لهذه الطفله من تحت الانقاض سته
ايام تحت الانقاض لطفله عمرها سبع سنوات
وكان لها شقيقتان تم انقاذهما قبل قليل
لكي ان تتخيلي هؤلاء الاطفال المعاناه
التي عاشوها فاطمه وبالتالي
الصدمات النفسيه التي عاشوها والازمه التي
عاشوها تحته هذه الانقاض لكن يعني الحمد
لله
انهم تمكنوا من اخراج ثلاث شقيقات الان
اخرجوا شقيقتين وبقيت الثالثه ما زالوا
يحاولون اخراجها ويبدو انهم في المراحل
الاخيره
نشاهد ان سيارات الاسعاف
بالضوء الازرق جاهزه الان وهذا مؤشر على
انه
الان زميل مصور هو اقرب مني لهم يقول لي
انهم يؤكدون بانها على قيد الحياه فاطمه
اذا فقط في انتظار ان يتم انتشال الطفله
الثالثه
واخراجها ومن ثم نقلها في سياره الاسعاف
هذه اخبار مفرحه
وساره جدا في ظل هذه الكارثه الانسانيه
الكبيره التي تعيشها البلاد نتحدث عن اكثر
من 120 ساعه سته ايام
طبعا فاطمه يعني يكون احد الاشخاص في داخل
هذه الثغرات او بين الانقاذ بين الانقاذ
دخل الى هذه الى هذا هذه الثغره او هذا
المكان
العميق داخل تحت الانقاض ليتمكن من سماع
اي اصوات
نعم فاطمه هيا هذه الطريقه احدى الطرق
المتبعه
كثير من العالقين يعني كانوا يصدرون اصوات
وبالتالي كانوا يستدلون اليهم ويحددون
مناطق تواجدهم والحفر اليهم بشكل مباشر
وهذا يساعدهم على يعني حصر نقاط البحث
والحفر بشكل مباشر وتقليل الوقت للوصول
اليهم بالاضافه الى استخدام الاجهزه
الحديثه
والكاميرات الحراريه والرادارات
للوصول الى هؤلاء الاشخاص لكن التحدي
الاكبر فاطمه الذي يواجه فرق الانقاذ هو
يعني الاف الاطنان من
انقاض التي يعني تنهار على انهارت على
رؤوس العالقين
وما زالت عمليات البحث ايضا مستمره وما
زال هناك تواجد لاحياء تحت الانقاض كما
شاهدنا فاطمه
الان فهمنا ان يعني الفتاه ما زالت على
قيد الحياه لكن الحمد لله
يبدو ان وضعها يعني وضع الانقاذ صعب
وبالتالي تحتاج الى وقت لاخراجها ومحاوله
يعني فكفكت الاجزاء من الانقاذ التي تحيط
بها
وعلى اي حال يعني هي اخبار مفرحه حتى هذه
اللحظه وجيده حتى هذه اللحظه
طبعا الذين يتمسكون بالامل
الساعات حتى يتم انقاذها ونحن باقون معك
غسان لمتابع
العمليه عمليه الانقاذ لحظه بلحظه حتى يتم
انتشال الطفله من تحت الانقاض هل سيتمكن
من الاستعانه بالمعدات والاليات هناك خطر
من استخدامها في هذه اللحظه غسان
فاطمه في هذه الحالات الاليه ثقيله تتدخل
في مرحله ما ثم تتوقف وتدخل بتتدخل
العناصر البشريه لاستخدام الادوات البسيطه
والمعدات الخفيفه حتى لا يؤذوا العالقين
الناجين الموجودين تحت الانقاذ الاليات
لها مرحله
تتحرك بشكل محدد معين ومن ثم تتوقف
وبالتالي تبدا مراحل اخرى من العمل وهو
عمل مضني وشاق جدا فاطمه
فهو يعني عمل شاق ومضني جدا وفي نفس الوقت
هو عمل خطير جدا لان اي خطا في عمليات
ازاله الانقاذ ممكن ان يتسبب بكارثه لا
سمح الله وبالتالي هذا
لماذا يحتاجون هذه البطانيه
سيخرجونها ربما
بطبيعه
يبدو انه ايضا هي مؤشرات على اقتراب
اخراجها يبدو انهم سيقتربون يعني الانباء
في هذا الموقع فاطمه المتضاربه جدا لا
نستطيع ان ناخذ يعني خبرا دقيقا
للظرف والوضع الحساس والمربك يعني الكل
يحاول الوصول باسرع
اخراج الطفله نحن يعني نشاهد حركه من تحت
الانقاذ لا ادري ان كنتم تشاهدونها حتى
هذه
فالان نحن بانتظار هذه اللحظات العصيبه ان
تنتهي وان يعني يزفي الفرح الى اهل هذه
الطفله والى باقي الاهالي الذين ما زالوا
ينتظرون العالقين ليعطيهم المزيد من الامل
يعطيهم المزيد من الامل
غسان خصوصا بعد اكثر من
122 ساعه بالفعل تم العثور على فتاتين تم
انقاذهم من تحت هذه الاوقات التي نشاهدها
مباشره مع موفدنا غسان وعبر كاميرا
العربيه في قهرمان مرعش تم انقاذ فتاتين
وتم نقلهم بالاسعاف مع خالهم على ما يبدو
مباشره الى المستشفى ويتم الان محاوله
انقاذ اختهم الثالثه والتي تبلغ من العمر
7 سنوات فرق الانقاذ يعملون على قدم
وساقوا وبلا كلل يبدو انهم ياتون
بالبطانيات ياتون بالت
لاخراج الفتاه من تحت الانقاذ ولكن غسان
كما ذكرت انت هناك ربما صعوبه بسبب كثرات
التراكم الانقاض فوقها وصعوبه اخراجها
ولكن سنتابع معك هذه المرحله لحظه بلحظه
حتى ان يتم اخراجها بالسلامه باذن الله
فرق الانقاذ المتواجده غسان هل هو فقط
دوليه
جميع هناك فرق محليه وفرق دوليه تشارك في
هذه العمليه الانقاذ وعلى ما اعتقد ان
فريق الانقاذ الذي يعمل الان حاليا
لاستخراج هذه الفتاه هو فريق انقاذ
اذربيجاني
يعمل الان على انقاذ هذه الفتاه نعم فريق
انقاذ اذربيجاني مع فريق انقاذ تركي ايضا
هناك عناصر من القوات المسلحه التركيه
موجوده في هذا الموقع طبعا فاطمه نحن نقف
في موقع حي كامل حي كامل سنريكم الصوره
عند اخراج الطفله سالمه باذن الله سنريكم
الصوره حي كامل مدمر نتحدث عن ابنيه من
عشره طوابق واكثر كلها سويت في الارض فلكي
ان تتخيلي هذا المشهد المرعب فما تشاهدون
تشاهدينه الان على الصوره هو مشهد متكرر
في مئات المواقع ربما الاف المواقع في حيث
نحن نقف وفي المدن الاخرى المنكوبه تتواصل
عمليات الاغاثه والانقاذ حتى الساعه لم
تتوقف بالامس كنا في هذا الموقع العمليات
متواصله عدنا صباح هذا اليوم متواصله على
مدار الساعه ليلا نهارا العمليات متواصله
بشكل كبير جدا فاطمه
نعم صحيح نعم صحيح هم سابقون الزمن الزمن
وهم في صراع مع الزمن الان الزمن هو الوحش
الذي يفتح فمه امام فرق الانقاذ وايضا
امام العالقين
الناجين تحت الانقاض وايضا امام الاهالي
وبالتالي هو شيء مرعب وشيء مخيف يضغط على
الجميع يضغط على
[موسيقى]
الاهالي ويضغط على فرق الانقاذ ويضغط
ويعملون الان كما علمنا يعملون الان على
رفع الانقاذ المحيطه من الفتاه الموجوده
تحت الانقاذ فكما قلت فهذا يشكل ضغط كبير
على جميع الموجودين هنا سواء كانوا من فرق
انقاذ والامن من اهالي امن يعني مؤسسات
موجوده تعمل على الارض على مدار الاربعه
شخصيه للفتيات على ما يبدو هناك شنطه
باللون الزهري خرجت اخرجوها هناك
نوع من يعني انت فاطمه تشاهدين الصوره
اوضح مني انت تشاهدينا صوره بصراحه اوضح
مني لاني انا
خلف المصور لا استطيع ان ارى
الزاويه التي تشاهدينها لكن نعم بالفعل اي
شيء يتم اخراجه حتى تتم تسهيل عمليه اخراج
الفتاه الان احد المنقذين يخرج من من اسفل
الانقاذ لا ندري ان كان اقترب خروج
الفتاحه هذه اللحظه ام لا
لا ندري ما هو الوضع حتى هذه اللحظه لكننا
نترقب على امل ان تخرج الفتاه بصحه جيده
ان شاء الله ونحن معك ولكن في هذه الاجزاء
عصيبه جدا بصراحه فاطمه بالفعل هي كذلك
وفي هذه الاثناء غسان النقل الفتيات الى
المستشفى ملء او الخطوات المتبعه بعد
نقلهم الى المستشفى والاطمئنان على حالتهم
هل يتم نقلهم الى مخيمات ما الاجراءات
المتبعه هل لديك معلومات حول ذلك
بطبيعه الحال يتم نقلهم الى المستشفى ويتم
تقديم العلاج العلاج اللازم لهم بالمستشفى
الى ان ينتهوا من هذه
الاجراءات الطبيه والصحيه اللي هي العالق
ومن ثم
ان كان لديه اهل يسلم الى اهله ثم يمضي مع
اهله ان كان في مخيم او مركز ايواء او بيت
او اي شيء اخر لكن ان كان لا يوجد احد
يتعرف على هذا الشخص او هذه الاطفال
تحديدا فاطمه يتم نقلهم الى العاصمه انقره
وتسليمهم لمؤسسات الدوله حتى يتم الوصول
الى اقارب هؤلاء طبعا يعني اخر الانباء
كانت تتحدث عن اكثر من 15 طفلا تم نقلهم
من
انقره من يعني مناطق المناطق المنقوبه الى
انقره
طائره عسكريه
لتحفظ عليهم في مؤسسات الدوله هناك
ومن ثم يعني الوصول الى اقارب لهؤلاء
الاطفال وتسليمهم طبعا هؤلاء الاطفال يعني
يكونوا قد فقدوا اهلهم بالكامل وبالتالي
لا يجدون احد
فتتولاهم مؤسسات الدوله التي تقدم لهم
الرعايه اللازمه والكامله سواء صحيه او
غير ذلك كل ما يحتاجه الاطفال يقدمونه لهم
فاطمه عموما فاطمه ما زالت عمليات الانقاذ
متواصله تاكدوا بان الفتاه ما زالت على
قيد الحياه الطفله الحياه
يواصلون عمليات ازاله الانقاذ من محيطه
حتى يتمكنوا من اخراجها لتوجد انباء حتى
اللحظه ما هي طبيعه الوضع تحت الانقاض
لكنها متواصله العمليه متواصله حتى هذه
اللحظه به تحديدا غسان يعني لا نرى اي
ازاله للانقاذ ام هناك امقاد داخليه يتم
ازالتها ما الذي نراه تحديدا هو العمل
بالدخل العمل بالداخل فاطمه العمل الان
يجري بالداخل لا ندري ما هو ما هي طبيعه
الوضع بالداخل ربما هناك اصابه للطفله
فيتم التعامل معها بشكل صحيح في الداخل
ربما هناك يعني ما زال انقاض هناك او
قضبان حديديه
قضبان حديديه في
مكان الوصول اليها يعيقها ربما يعني لا
ندري ما هي طبيعه الوضع وبالتالي هم
يتعاملون مع الوضع لحظه بلحظه وثانيه نعم
كل الاحتمالات نعم صحيح الان يعني ابلغني
الزميل المصور باسل بانهم ادخلوا كلب مدرب
الى داخل هذه الثغره
يحمل هذا الكلبه كاميرا حراريه او كاميرا
يستطيعون رؤيه ما يحدث بالداخل ام ما دور
الكربونه تحديدا
[موسيقى]
الكلاب هنا عاده فاطمه
تنبه المنقذين والعناصر البشريه ان هناك
شخص حي فان كان حيا ينبح الكلب وبالتالي
هم يتاكدون بان هناك شخص حي الان الكلب
يدخل
لا ندري ما الوضع بالتحديد لكننا ما زلنا
بانتظار هذه
اللحظات العصيبه والصعبه جدا ونحن ننتظر
معك غسان يعني نستذكر بان رجال الاغاثه
انقذوا امراه حامل في شهرها السادس
وابنتها البالغه من العمر سبع سنوات بعد
قضاء اكثر من 115 ساعه بين اكوام انقاض
مبنى سوي بالارض في مدينه غازي عنتاب
التركيه اثراء طبعا هذا الزلزال وايضا تم
العثور على
اطفال كذلك في الساعات الماضيه تحت
الانقاض وهم على قيد الحياه وايضا تم
اخراجهم واجرائهم واسعافهم
اقرب مستشفى من المنطقه المنكوبه التي
تواجدوا بها في تركيا
دخلت عمليات الانقاذ في تركيا وسوريا طبعا
يومها السادس واخر حصيله تشير الى سقوط
اكثر من 25 الف
وفاه وعشرات الالاف من المصابين في
البلدين في تركيا تحديدا حيث نشاهد هذه
الصور المباشره من قهرمان مرعش عبر كاميرا
العربيه ارتفع عدد القتلى اثر الزلزال الى
20,665 مع اجلاء ما يقرب من 93,000 وهذا
الرقم في تزايد كما نشاهد مباشره هنا تم
اجراء فتاتين ويتم الان عمليه انقاذ
والبحث عن الفتاه الثالثه البالغه من
العمر 7 سنوات تحت هذا المبنى الذي سوي
بالارض اثراء السلسال اداره الكوارث
والطوارئ اشارت الى ان
1891 هز ارتداديه وقعت منذ ان ضرب الزلزال
الاول البلاد فجره الاثنين الماضي هذا عن
سوريا هذا عن تركيا اما في سوريا
وصل عدد القتلى جراء الزلزال الى
4500 وفق تصريحات المرصد السوري وكانت
هناك انباء تحدثت من الخود البيضاء بان
عمليات البحث والانقاذ هناك في سوريا قد
توقفت بسبب نقص المعدات ونقص الاليات ونقص
الادوات التي تساعد في البحث عن احياء تحت
الانقاض ان كان من الات حراريه ان كان من
كلاب بوليسيه مدربه ان كان من اليات ثقيله
تساعد طبعا تنقص هذه المعدات والادوات في
سوريا لذلك تم اعلان في حماه تحديدا ثم
وقف عمليات البحث عن احياء منذ قرابه
اليومين في حلب كانوا شارفوا على الانتهاء
واعلان وقف عمليات الانقاذ ولكن عمليات
البحث عن الجثث ما زالت قائمه كما تحدثوا
مراسلين او شبكه مراسلين في تركيا وسوريا
رغم فقدان الامل من وجود احياء في سوريا
الا ان البحث ما زال قائم الجثث للرغبه في
تكريمهم ودفنهم بالشكل الصحيح من قبل
عوائلهم نعود الى غسان وهذه الصور
المباشره لقهرمان مرعش وعمليات انقاذ وتم
قبل دقائق قليله كما شاهدنا عبر كاميرا
العربيه مباشره انقاذ فتاتين وتم نقلهم
عبر الاسعاف مع خالهم والان يتم الترقب
لاخراج اختهم الثالثه والبالغه من العمر 7
سنوات ماذا لديك غسان حتى اللحظه هل من
جديد هل فهمتم ما الذي يجري تحديدا وكيف
هو وضع الفتى ربما
حتى اللحظه الا جديد العمل ما زال مستمر
وما زلنا ننتظر
فرق الانقاذ ما زالت تتعامل مع الوضع الان
يحاولون اخراج الفتاه من تحت الانقاض وما
زالت هذه العمليه مستمره حتى هذه اللحظه
طبعا بطبيعه الحال فاطمه ستستمر عمليه
الانقاذ الى ان يخرجوا الفتى وما زالت
متواصله حتى هذه اللحظه وحتى هذه الساعه
لا توجد ايه معلومات حتى هذه اللحظه جديده
حول الوضع
او طبيعه وضع الفتاه وضعها الصحي او ما
الذي يجري اسفل الانقاض وما الذي يؤخر هذه
العمليه لكل السيناريوهات مطروحه ربما
هناك انقاذ يعني متراكمه على جزء من جسد
الفتاه ربما
لا يستطيعون تحريك او يريدون تحريك بطريقه
حذره جدا ربما تكون مصابه ربما نحن لا
نتمنى ذلك لكن على اي حل ما زلنا بانتظار
انتشال او اخراج هذه الفتاه على قيد
الحياه لكن المعلومات المؤكده حتى هذه
اللحظه ان ان الفتى يعني الاسعاف موجود
المسعفين موجودون وكذلك ان راينا بطانيات
وراينا ايضا يعني ادوات
لانتشال الفتاه حال خروجها من تحت الانقاذ
نعم صحيح كل الادوات متوفره وكل الوسائل
متوفره
لانقاذ العالقين سواء كان من سيارات اسعاف
او منقودين او مسعفين طبعا المنقذون
يقوموا بتسليم
المصاب او العالق الناجي للمسعفين تقدم له
الاسعافات الهويه الاوليه بطبيعه الحال في
سياره الاسعاف يتم تزويدهم بالاكسجين حتى
تحت الانقاض ومن ثم يتم اخراجهم وادخالهم
لسياره الاسعاف
ويعني تقدم لهم الاسعافات الاوليه وما هو
مطلوب في تلك اللحظه ومن ثم يتم توجه بهم
الى المستشفيات لتقديم العلاج اللازم وكل
الاجراء
يشير لشخص اخر بان يجب يجلب له اداه تكسير
يبدو انه يطلب ادوات تكسير
للاستمرار في عمليه الانقاذ هذه غسان
يعني هناك نقطه لافته ربما غسان لا ادري
ان كنت تتفق ولكن على ما يبدو بانها في
هذه المنطقه التي تتواجد فيها انت تحديدا
هناك في خلال الساعات الماضيه الكثير من
عمليات الانقاذ لاحياء تحت الانقاض هل
يعني عمليات انقاذ مستمره والعثور على
احياء مستمر في المناطق الاخرى المنكوبه
في تركيا ام في هذه المنطقه هي الاكثر
تحديدا
لا فاطمه ولكن قبل ان تجيب غساله اسمح لي
ان اشير بانهم على ما يبدو اتوا بمطرقه
لمكان تواجد الفتاه يعني تكسير ربما
وازاحه للحديد على ما يبدو لانك ذكرت قبل
قليل غسان انهم طلبوا سكين كذلك
نعم صحيح نعم صحيح وانت فاطمه يعني
تشاهدين الصوره افضل مني انا لا استطيع
الوصول لارى المشهد من الزاويه التي
تلتقطها الكاميرا بالتالي هم يطلبون كل
الادوات اللازمه التي يحتاجونها نعم التي
يحتاجونها للمساعده في اخراج الفتاه وكل
السيناريوهات مطروحه ربما هناك يعني بعض
الانقاذ الاسمنتيه تعيق عمليه الاخراج
وبالتالي هم يطلبون هذه الادوات البسيطه
للتعامل مع انقاذ هذه الطفله طبعا يقول
التعامل معها بحرص شديد يبدو انه خرج من
الثغره الموجوده تحت الانقاض ونحاول ان
نفهم ما الذي يجري ولكن كنا نتحدث غسان عن
ايضا
العثور على احياء تحت الانقاذ في مناطق
اخرى كنت تقول لي
فاطمه بطبيعه الحال يعني
الانباء التي ترد من حول انقاذ عالقين ليس
فقط من كهرمان مرعش ترد من المناطق الاخرى
يعني كما ذكرتي قبل قليل بالخبر بان هناك
سيده عمرها 55 عام تم انقاذها بعد سته
ايام من تحت الانقاذ في ديار بكر وايضا
هناك في هاتاي والمناطق المتضرره وبالتالي
يعني
العالقين الناجين ربما يكونوا موجودين في
كل مكان يعني هم ليسوا في مكان محدد
مع مرور سته ايام
تتضاءل فرص النجاح لكننا الان نشاهد كما
نشاهد عبر شاشه العربيه انقاذ طفلتين قبل
قليل وننتظر انقاذ الطفله الثالثه التي
تبلغ من العمر سبع سنوات وربما هذه
الانباء الساره تتوالى يعني خلال الساعات
المقبله سواء في كهرمان مرعش او في باقي
المناطق العشر التي تضررت نتيجه هذا
الزلزال بطبيعه الحال ما زال العمل متواصل
حتى هذه اللحظه وعمليات الانقاذ متواصله
هذه حتى هذه اللحظه والعديد من الاشخاص
يعني يقولون بان هناك
ناجين ما زالوا تحت الانقاض والعمل
المتواصل
لمحاوله انتشال هؤلاء وكما قلنا ان التحدي
الاكبر الذي يواجه فرق الانقاذ هو يعني
الاف الاطنان من
الانقاض التي تتراكم فوق رؤوس
العالقين وهو تحدي كبير يعني في بدايه
الزلزال كان هناك ايضا حاله الطقس السيئه
جدا كان هناك ثلوج وامطار وايضا هذا كان
يعرقل عمليات الانقاذ ويؤخر عمليات
الانقاذ لكن لكن
لكن يطلبون منا المغادره الان لا ندري
لماذا نحاول البقاء مكاننا على الاقل لو
بقيت الكاميرا
ربما اوشك على خرج لكنهم يحاولون منا
يطلبوا منا الان مغادره نحاول ان نفاوضهم
للبقاء
طلبوا منا تغيير المكان
قدر المستطاع
سنحاول سنحاول نعم سنحاول البقاء في
مكاننا
سنحاول
سنحاول البقاء الان
لمحاوله رصد هذه اللحظات يعني المفرحه في
هذه الكارثه الانسانيه طبعا فكما كنت اقول
انا كان يعني في اول يومين كانت حاله
الطقس سيئه جدا كان هناك امطار وثلوج
وبالتالي كان ذلك يؤثر بشكل كبير على
عمليات الانقاذ الان يعني الايام الثلاثه
الاخيره الجو صحوا مشمس حتى وان كانت
درجات الحراره متدنيه لكن لا يوجد ثلوج لا
يوجد امطار تعيق عمليات الانقاذ
تبقى يعني
تدني درجات الحراره هي
العائق الذي يواجه العالقين وجه العالقين
اثناء انتظارنا خروج الفتاه العالقه تحت
الانقاض والبالغه من العمر سبع سنوات غسان
هل لك ان تحدثنا ربما عن المساعدات التي
اتت لقهرمان مرعش
نعم بالفعل المساعدات متواصله متواصله لا
تنقطع فاطمه سواء كان من المؤسسات سواء
كان من المؤسسات الحكوميه من هيئه الكوارث
والطوارئ التركيه او مؤسسات المجتمع
المدني او حتى الهبات الشعبيه وهناك ايضا
مساعدات انسانيه تصل من الخارج ايضا الى
تركيا وتتوزع على باقي المناطق في باقي
المناطق المتضرره والمنكوبه في البلاد بما
فيها كهرمان مرعش طبعا جميع المساعدات
يمكن يعني ملاحظتها بالعين المجرده في كل
مكان في كل شارع تتجولين فيه فاطمه ممكن
ان تشاهدي حتى الناس العاديين جاؤوا من
المناطق والولايات البعيده
وقاموا بالنصب خيام
لطهو الطعام وايضا تقديم
التغطيه والمياه التغطيه والمياه وكل شيء
كل شيء يحتاجه
المتضررون هنا في هذه المناطق تقدم لهم
المساعدات المساعدات لم تنقطع ولم تتوقف
وتتواصل على مدار الساعه ويوميا قوافل
المساعدات يمكن يعني مشاهدتها في الشوارع
تتوجه الى المناطق المتضرره كل الانواع
المساعدات تقدم هنا
للمتضررين فاطمه
يبقى التحدي امام فرق الانقاذ الان التي
تصارع الوقت وتسابق الزمن للوصول الى ما
يمكن الوصول اليه من عالقين ناجين تحت
الانقاذ
ينزلون كما نعلم ان الى مكان تواجد الفتى
العالقه تحت الانقاذ غسان يعني لا نود
ارباكهم ولكن هل ربما تتمكن الحديث مع اي
شخص يتحدث العربيه او يتمكن ان يشرح لنا
ماذا يحدث او ماذا يرون بالداخل هل هذا
ممكن
عفوا فاطمه لم اسمع السؤال جيدا الصوت
يتقطع
طلب منكم
حديث الكاميرا غسان ام تتمكنون من البقاء
حيث انتم وان نرى مكان تواجد الطفله نحاول
نحاول نحاول البقاء نحاول البقاء حيث نحن
حتى نرصد لحظه اخراج الطفله لكن
الفرق الانقاذ وعناصر الجيش تطلب منا ان
نتحرك ان نبتعد قليلا لكن انهم ياتون
اداه الاسعاف او السرير الاسعافي الذي
يحملون يحملون به المصابين على ما يبدو
احد المنقذين نعم الان كما نشاهد باسل
باسل صور الان يعني نشاهد
من المغذي الطبي الاملاح
والنقاله وهذا مؤشر جيد قوي على ان الطفل
على قيد الحياه والان الطفله اقتربت من
الخروج كما قلنا قبل قليل بان الاجراءات
الطبيه اللازمه والسريعه تقدم فور خروج
تقدم فور خروج
النجين من تحت الانقاض الان نشاهد
فرق الاسعاف تجهز النقاله وتجهز الاملاح
لتعامل مع الطفله التي ستخرج بعد قليل
وانقطع الاتصال انقطع الاتصال نحن معك
غسان نسمعك ونتابع الصور مباشره لحظه
بلحظه نحن معك لا ادري ان كنتم تسمعوني ام
لا لكن الان
لكننا الان نشاهد هذه اللحظات
الصعبه والمفرحه
عفوا
نسمعك غسان ونتابع معك هذه الصور المباشره
عبر كاميرا العربيه
يبدو انه هناك يعني نحن على غضون لحظات من
اخراج طفله عالقه تحت الاوقات وتبلغ من
العمر 7 سنوات على ما يبدو هم من سوريا تم
انقاذ اثنين من اخواتها الاكبر عمرا منها
وحده بالغه تسع سنوات والاخرى بالغه احدى
عشر سنه وتم اخراجهم بالاسعاف مع خالهم
والان نترقب خروج اختهم الاصغر سنا
والبالغه من العمر 7 سنوات يبدو اننا يعني
على بعد لحظات من اخراجها فرق الانقاذ
اتوبي المغذي اتوبي الناقل الذي ينقلون به
المصابين كما نشاهد على هذه الصور
المباشره امامنا تم ادخال الكلاب المدربه
للتاكد من انها على قيد الحياه وبالفعل تم
تحسين
الان فاطمه طلبوا اضاءه هم يستخدمون
كشافات واضاءه
لاناره هذه الثغره لكن واضح ان المؤشرات
ما نشاهده الان من نقاله ومنه تدخل فريق
الاسعاف
وتهيئه وتاهبه لي
تعامل مع الفتاه او الطفله التي تبلغ من
العمر سبع سنوات التي سيتم اخراجها يعني
خلال لحظات مقبله طبعا هي
الطفله الثالثه الان يتم استخراجها في هذه
الساعه
انقذوا شقيقي شقيقاتها اثنتان من شقيقاتها
قبل تقريبا نصف ساعه من الان وهم الان
يتعاملون مع الشقيقه الثالثه وتبلغ من
العمر سبع سنوات شقيقاتها الاخرى واحده 11
عاما 11 سنه والثانيه تسعه سنوات وما زال
العمل جاري لانقاذ الثالثه
وننتظر هذه اللحظات وكما قلنا ان فريق
الاسعاف يتاهب الان
الحركه زادت بين المنقذين هناك نشاط في
الحركه ويبدو ان يعني الفتاه تقترب لكن ما
زلنا ننتظر هذه اللحظه فاطمه وهي تدل على
ان وقت خروج الفتاه من تحت الانقاض على
يقترب اكثر فاكثر كل لحظه نحن نتابع معك
هذه المرحله وهذه العمليه لانقاذها يعني
شاهدنا معك غسان وتابعنا استخدام ادوات
تكسير استخدام سكين لاستخدام الكلاب
البوليسيه واخراج الانقاض والان ذكرت
بانهم طلبوا اضاءه وايضا راينا فرق
الاسعاف ياتون بالناقل او النواقل
المصابين واكياس التغذيه كيس التغذيه
لاسعاف الفتاه فورا ومباشره حال خروجها من
تحت الانقاض نحن معك ونتابع هذه الصور
المباشره غسان لعمليه الانقاذ هذه
نعم نعم صحيح فاطمه لا زلنا نرصد هذه
اللحظات عبر شاشه العربيه
ننتظر هذه اللحظات السعيده والمفرحه طبعا
يعني مشاهد الموت ومشاهد الدمار
محزنه ومؤسفه وثقيله جدا على الجميع هنا
في تركيا مثل هذه الحالات هي بصيص امل مثل
هذه الحالات تعطي يعني فرحه وتعطي املا
خصوصا للاخرين الذين ما زالوا فاطمه
ينتظرون اي انباء عن اذويهم العالقين تحت
الانقاض هناك امل كبير مازال الاهالي بعض
اليوم الخامس هناك يعني لا امل هناك ولا
حاجه للمزيد من البحث على احياء نحن الان
في اليوم السادس بعد الزلزال الذي وقع فجر
الاثنين وما زال هناك احياء وما زال يتم
العثور عليهم ولابد يعني كما نرى من
استمراريه عمليات الانقاذ والبحث
اي احياء تحت الانقاض غسان
نعم صحيح نعم صحيح فاطمه يعني المعدل
الزمني هو ثلاثه ايام او 72 ساعه ومن ثم
تتضائل نسب او فرص النجالي العالقين وتصل
الى 5% في اليوم الخامس لكن نحن نتحدث عن
اليوم السادس وما زلنا يعني تردنا الانباء
عن انقاذ ناجين من تحت الانقاذ سواء كانت
سيده في الخمسه وخمسين من عمرها او 60 رجل
يبلغ من العمر 60 عاما ايضا هناك تم
انقاذه وايضا نتحدث عن اطفال رضع فاطمه
ايضا تم انقاذهم بعد اكثر من 90 ساعه
وبالتالي هذا يعطي امل كبير في وجود
المزيد من
العالقين الناجين تحت الانقاض وانقاذه
هؤلاء لكن لا ننسى فاطمه ان
حجم الدمار كبير يمتد على
500 كيلو متر في جنوب تركيا ولا ننسى ان
حجم الدمار الكبير الذي طالع الاف المباني
نتحدث عن اكثر من
6400 مبنى دمر بالكامل هذه الاحصائيات
الاوليه فاعداد الناس كبيره وكبيره جدا
تحت الانقاض وبالتالي هذا ما يفسر وجود
ناجين يخرجون حتى هذه اللحظه لكن هي ايضا
يعني لطف من الله بان يعني مثل هؤلاء
الاطفال والرضع والمسنين ان يستطيعوا
الخروج بعد هذا الفتره الان ينقلون
الانقاض من داخل يقومون بتكسير فاطمه
الانقاض وكومونا بابعادها عن طريق الفتاه
على ما يبدو يستخدمون
يستخدمون
يستخدمون ادوات نقل بسيطه وادوات يعني
مطرقه وازميل
هذه
نعم صحيح
نعم نحن نسمع صوت الطرق ويقومون بنقل
الانقاض بادوات بسيطه لابعادها عن طريق
الفتى ما زلنا يعني
بانتظار هذه اللحظه الصعبه
ونحن ننتظر فاطمه
نعم مثل هذه الانباء فاطمه تعطي الامل في
بقيه الحي الموجود
وفي بقيه المناطق عندما تنشر على وسائل
الاعلام ووسائل التواصل الاجتماعي
وبالتالي تبث الامل من جديد في نفوس
الاهالي الذين ما زالوا ينتظرون اي انباء
عن ذويهم العالقين حتى هذه اللحظه هناك
عائلات كامله تبيت امام الانقاض فاطمه
بانتظار اي نبا عن اطفالهم او ذويهم
العالقين تحت الانقاض رغم بروده الطقس
ورغم شده بروده الطقس خلال ساعات الليل
التي تصل الى مادون الصفر ومع ذلك يزال
يعني يبقون امام هذه المباني وهذه الانقاذ
يعني انتظار اي خبر مفرح او اي امل ممكن
ان يخرج من تحت الانقاض
ولغايه اللحظه لم تعلن السلطات التركيه
وقف
عمليات الانقاذ عمليات الانقاذ مستمره
وبالتالي ما زال الامل موجود حتى هذه
اللحظه على امل اخراج المزيد قبل قليل
غسان اخراج فتاتين اختاه الفتاه العالقه
حاليا هل لك ان تستذكر معنا هذه اللحظات
غسان
نعم بالفعل يعني لحظات صعبه وكنتم شاهدتم
خال الفتاتين كيف يعني
يعني في حاله صدمه وذهول وفي حاله فرح
يعني حاله حاله مشاعر مختلطه يكاد لا يصدق
ما يراه يعني
دموع الفرح في عينيه والصدمه والذهول كانت
تسيطر عليه ويعني كان في حاله من الفرح
الشديد
كان في حاله من الفرح الشديد رافق طبعا
بنات يعني الفتاتين الى المستشفى لتقديم
العلاج اللازم وهو بانتظار الان
الشقيقه الثالثه على امل ان تخرج
بسلامه الان لكن كل المؤشرات فاطمه تشير
الى ان الفتاه على الاقل بصحه جيده
المسعفون جاهزون بالمغذيات
كل الاجراءات اللازمه لنقلها من هذا
المكان الى سياره الاسعاف ومن ثم الى
المستشفى
حتى اللحظه لا جديد حتى اللحظه لا جديد
ننتظر
اللحظات يعني والترقب لبصيص امل ولحظه فرح
اخرى من اخراج هذه الفتاه هذه الطفله
البالغه من العمر سبع سنوات يعطي المزيد
من الامل للاحياء الاخرى والمناطق الاخرى
المنكوبه للاستمرار في عمليه البحث
والاستمرار في عمليه رفع الانقاذ والبحث
عن احياء تحت هذه المباني التي سويت
بالارض اثراء الزلزال الذي وقع فجر
الاثنين الماضي غسان يعني
عمليات الانقاذ قائمه كما ذكرت لنا في
مئات المناطق المتضرره من الزلزال
والانباء ترد بان هناك ايضا احياء تم
انقاذهم كما ذكرنا هناك امراه مسنه
البالغه من العمر 70 عاما ايضا تم انقاذها
من قهرمان مرعش وهناك امراه بالغه من
العمر 55 عاما تم انقاذها من ديار بكر
هناك اطفال رضع كذلك يتم اج اخراجهم
وانقاذهم من تحت الانقاذ خلال الساعات
القليله الماضيه يعني نحن في اليوم السادس
نحن
مررنا على اكثر من 125 ساعه منذ الزلزال
معك غسان
يعني على ما يبدو على ما يبدو اني استطيع
مشاهده لست متاكدا لكن الموقف يعني لا
ادري على اني استطيع ان اشاهد يعني الطرف
ساق الفتاه لست متاكدا فاطمه لكن هناك
حركه تحت الانقاذ من الزاويه التي انا اقف
فيها نحاول التاكد لا ندري ان كانت هي ام
لا نحن معك لحظه
هذه حتى هذه اللحظه مستمره فاطمه
وما نشاهده الان وهو واضح امامي الان انهم
يقومون بتكسير الانقاذ من داخل هذه الثغره
وسحبها واخراجها الى الخارج لي تسهيل خروج
الطفله التي تبلغ من العمر 7 سنوات ساعات
يعني لحظات عصيبه جدا على على فرق الانقاذ
وعلى
الطفله نفسها فاطمه يعني نتحدث عن سته
ايام تحت الانقاذ في هذا الطقس البارد لا
طعام ولا غذاء ولا ولا اي شيء
الوضع صعب جدا في هذه اللحظات
على امل ان تخرج سالمه ان شاء الله يعني
ما زالت مستمره ننتظر بان هذه الفرق التي
ترتدي الخوض الحمراء هم فرق اذربيجانيه
ماذا عن الفرق الذين يرتدون الخوض الصفراء
والستر الصفراء كذلك
عليهم العلم التركي هم اتراك هذه يعني هذا
الاسعاف التركي على ما اعتقد الذي يحمل
المغذي في يده هذا الاسعاف التركي ايضا
هناك هيئه الطوارئ والكوارث التركيه
موجوده في المكان يعني اكثر من جهه تكون
موجوده في كل موقع يعني
استخدامه
للفتاه حال اخراجها من تحت الانقاض
واسعافها فورا حال اخراجها تفضل غسان
كما تشاهدين الان بالصوره المقربه
نعم نحاول رصد ما يمكن رصده من هذه
المسافه لكن يعني ما نشاهده انا الان هناك
انقاذ يتم اخراجها من هذه الثغره
وتخليصها
وقذفها الى خارج
الثغره
لتسهيل عمليه اخراج الطفله البالغه من
العمر سبع سنوات كما تشاهدين في الصوره
هناك العشرات في هذا الموقع من عمال
الانقاض طبعا الانقاذ الان يعني طلبوا
اله بسيطه
الانقاض تدخل هذه الاله الان
واضح انهم ما زالوا يعانون المزيد من
الحطام غسان هل استطعت ان ترى ما هي الاله
التي ثم طلب
لتكسير الحطام
يبدو انهم يواجهون صعوبه في الادوات
التقليديه المطرقه والزميل وبالتالي هي
تسهل عليهم هذه العمليه وكما كنت اقول بان
كل مكان او كل بنايه يتم العمل عليها يكون
هناك العشرات من عناصر فرق الانقاذ لك ان
تتخيلين نتحدث عن الاف المباني لكي ان
تتخيلي عن
عدد عناصر الفرق الانقاذ الموجوده في
البلاد هناك الالاف منهم يعملون على مدار
الساعه
لمحاوله انقاذ العالقين الناجين الموجوده
الموجودين تحت الانقاض طبعا في اكثر من
مكان
دائما او يقال بان هناك ناجين تحت هذه
الانقاذ لكن عمليات الحفر المتواصله
وكما قلنا قبل قليل بان عمليات الحفر
معقده جدا فاطمه وصعبه جدا وبالتالي هم يت
بحذر نحن قبل نصف ساعه واقل من ساعه رصدنا
اخراج شقيقتين وبقيت الثالثه لنا الان
ساعه كامله نحاول ننتظر اخراج الشقيقه
الثالثه ولغايه الان لم تخرج وبالتالي
العمليه هذا يوضح كم هي العمليه معقده جدا
وصعبه صعبه جدا فاطمه لاخراج
العالقين نعم نعم
بالمزيد من الاضرار لها لذلك يعني
يعملون على اقل من مهلهم وبحذر شديد
نعم يعملون بحذر شديد طبعا هم مختصون في
هذه الامور وبالتالي يتعاملون مع الامر
بحذر شديد ناهيك عن يعني تعريض الفتاه
للخطر هناك ايضا خطر الانقاض نفسها ممكن
ان يكون هناك يعني اي حركه خاطئه ممكن ان
تؤدي الى مزيد من الانهيار وبالتالي فقدان
فرص النجالي اي شخص عالق تحت الانقاض
وبالتالي هذا هو التحدي الكبير الذي يواجه
فرق الانقاذ فاطمه هذا هو او هذه هي
المشكله الكبيره التي تواجه فرق الانقاذ
وهو التعامل مع هذه الانقاض نتحدث عن
بنايات يعني اكثر من عشره طوابق انهارت
على رؤوس ساكنيها سويت بالارض فاطمه
وبالتالي التعامل مع هذه الاطنان من
الانقاض صعب جدا وما يعقد الامر ايضا
فاطمه هي الهزات الارتداديه كما ذكرت قبل
قليل ان هناك اكثر من الف هزه ارتداديه
رصدتها السلطات التركيه منذ الزلزال منذ
منذ اليوم يوم الاثنين الماضي وبالتالي كل
الظ
الوقت يعني نحن في اليوم السادس كما ذكرنا
وما زالوا يتمسكون بالحياه وما زالوا
يتمسكون بالامل وما زالوا يعني يصارعون
ليبقوا على قيد الحياه تحت هذه الانقاض
رغم الظروف الصعبه من عدم وجود غذاء من
عدم وجود ماء من عدم وجود تدفئه لهم كذلك
غسان يعني الان نترقب هذه اللحظات معك ومع
المشاهدين عبر كاميرا العربيه مازال فاطمه
يستخرجون ما زالوا فاطمه ما زالوا
يستخرجون انقاذ من تحت
الان احد عناصر الانقاذ خرج من داخل
الثغره
كان في الداخل هذا الشخص الذي تشاهدينه
الان في الكاميرا في الشاشه كانت داخل
الثغره وخرج الان
وما زالوا ايضا يسحبون مزيد من
الحطام ويخرجونه في هذه الادوات البسيطه
نعم بالفعل فاطمه يبقى الامل هو الشيء
الوحيد الذي يتمسك به هؤلاء لا ادري ان
كنت تشاهدين وجه المنقذ كيف يبدو عليه
التعب والارهاق نعم هذه هذا هو الوضع هذا
هو الوضع هو على كل حال هو احد عناصر
الجيش التركي هذا الذي خرج الان
صعوبه وتعقيد هذه
العمليه عمليه الانقاذ هذه ولكن يبقى ان
نترقب خروج الفتره بعد ذلك نفهم ما الذي
حدث وما الذي يجري تحديدا
نعم صحيح نعم صحيح
ما زالت العمليات مستمره حتى هذه اللحظه
ونترقى بخروجها دخل رجل انقاذ اخر الى
داخل هذه الثغره
لاول واضح انهم ما زالوا يخرجون الركن
يطلبون من الصمت الان فاطمه يطلبون اترك
الكلمه لك فاطمه نحن معك ونتابع لحظه
بلحظه هذه الصور المباشره معكم مشاهدينا
للحظات الصمت التي طلبت من فرق الانقاذ
لجميع المتواجدين في هذه المنطقه ليتمكنوا
من سماع اي صوت يصدر من تحت الانقاض لانه
يعلمون بان هناك فتاه على قيد الحياه تبلغ
من العمر 7 سنوات لانه تم قبل دقائق قليله
انقاذ اثنين من شقيقاتها وتم نقلهم
بالاسعاف مع خالهم اذا نشاهد معكم لحظات
صمت لفرق الانقاذ في قهرمان مرعش في تركيا
لمحاوله سماع اي صوت يصدر فرق الانقاذ
يعني تعمل على قدم وساق لمحا استخراج هذه
الطفله كان هناك ازاله يعني سريعه للركام
قدر المستطاع طبعا وبحذر كان هناك جلب
واستعداد لسياره الاسعاف ناقله الاسعاف
كما نشاهد في يد المسعف امامنا على الشاشه
هناك كيس مغذي ليستخدمونه للطفله حاله
اخراجها من تحت الركام الكاميرا العربيه
تتابع معكم لحظه بلحظه هذه اللحظات ولكن
على ما يبدو بعد استخدام الاليات الحراريه
والمطرقه والسكين وكذلك
ادوات بدائيه كثيره لمحاوله ازاله بعض من
الانقاض حول الفتى ما زال هناك صعوبه وما
زال هناك تعقيد بطبيعه الحال
لاخراجها ونحن نترقب معكم هذه اللحظه على
امل ان تخرج وهي سالمه معافى ويتم اسعافها
فور خروجها
ما زالت لحظات الصمت مستمره في هذا الموقع
وهذا المبنى المنهار
الزلزال الذي وقع فجر الاثنين الماضي وكان
بقوه اكثر من سبعه فاصله خمسه على مقياس
ريختر وبعمق اكثر من 17 كيلو متر وهو من
اشد الزلازل الذي ضربت المنطقه منذ 1999
فرق الانقاذ منذ سته ايام وهي تعمل بلا
كلل وبلا تعب
مساعدات وفرق انقاذ اتوا من حول العالم
للمساعده على ما يبدو ان لحظات اخرى على
ما اعتقد على ما اعتقد
فاطمه على ما اعتقد انهم
استدعوا خالها
ما زالوا يطلبون منا الصمت لكن ساحاول
نعم ونحن معك ساحاول ان اتحدث بصوت منخفض
فاطمه سنحترم لحظات الصمت وسنبقى معك
نتابع الصور عبر الكاميرا كاميرا العربيه
لهذه اللحظات ما زالت لحظات الصمت مستمره
على ما يبدو ان فرق الانقاذ يستدعون شخص
ما يقول العربيه غسان بانه خال الطفله
الذي رايناه قبل قليل ايضا عبر كاميرا
العربيه خرج مع الشقيقتين اللتان تم
انقاذهم قبل قليل
ويبلغون من العمر 9 سنوات و 11 سنه كذلك
على ما يبدو انه تطمان عليهم
اخذهم الى المستشفى والان عاد الى الموقع
ليطمئن على الشقيقه الثالثه والبالغه من
العمر 7 سنوات
كما يعني ذكرنا لكم مشاهدينا ان هذه
اللحظات يعني حاسمه لحظات يعني حرجه جدا
لخطوره الموقف
يعني دقه العمليه لاخراج هذه الفتاه لانهم
يواجهون ركام لمبنى يبلغ اكثر من ست سبع
طوابق وقع على رؤوسهم سوي بالارض والان
يحاولون انقاذ ما يمكن انقاذه واخراج
الاحياء تحت الانقاذ وهنا تحديدا نعلم
بوجود فتاه طفله تبلغ من العمر سبعه سنوات
هذه العمليه مباشره الان في قهرمان مرعش
جنوب تركيا
نشاهدها معكم لحظه بلحظه
للحظات الصمت لمحاوله سماع ما يمكن سماعه
من هذه الطفله العالقه ويبدو ان هذه
العائله عائله من سوريا
خرجوا من الاوضاع الماساويه في سوريا
يواجهوا كارثه فاطمه
يستخدمون يستخدمون جهاز لاستشعار الصوت
كما تشاهدين بس ان كان بالامكان اظهار هذا
الجهاز الذين يريدون استخدامه الان في هذه
اللحظات يحاولون استخدام جهاز الاستشعار
الصوت
كانت واضح الصوره لديكم لمحاوله
رصد او تحديد ربما موقع
تقف رجال الامن حاجز بيننا وبين هذا
الجهاز لكنه الان جلبوا جهاز لاستشعار
الصوت
وسيستخدمون هذا الجهاز ربما لتحديد موقع
نعم نعم جهاز يعني على اي حال لا ادري
بالضبط هو لكنه واضح انه لتحديد موقع
الفتاه بالضبط يبدو انهم لا يعرفون باي
جهه لانهم لانهم عندما طلبوا منا لحظه
الصمت الان قبل قليل فاطمه كان احد
المنقضين داخل هذه الثغره وكان ينادي كنا
نسمعه من الداخل ينادي وعلى ما يبدو انهم
حاولوا ان يطلبوا شخص اخر عربي ليتخاطب
معها حتى تفهم عليه لا ادري بالضبط لكن
نحن نحاول نحاول ان نفهم الان هذا ما يجري
خالها موجود
لا اراها الان لكنه
لكنه موجود يعني كما علمت خالها وربما
يريدون مساعده خالها في يعني ادخاله
ومحاوله الحديث معها
لتجاوب معه وتحديد مكانها بالضبط لكن على
اي حال ما زالت العمليات متواصله هذه
لحظات الصمت فاطمه هي
الصمت من ذهب انجاز التعبير هذا هو الصمت
الذي من الذهب في هذه اللحظات واغلى من
الذهب هو هذا الصمت الذي يعم جميع مناطق
تركيا
الجنوبيه التي تعرضت للزلزال
في كل مكان يطلب الصمت
والان
يطلب الصمت مجددا اذا لحظات اخرى وجديده
ذات عمليه الانقاذ للطفله البالغه من
العمر 7 سنوات الطفله السوريه
خالها معها في الموقع كان قد ذهب الى
المستشفى مع اثنين من شقيقاتها
وتم انقاذهم من هذا المبنى تحديدا وقبل
الدقائق قليله ايضا شهدناها عبر كاميرا
العربيه
الفتاتان تبلغان من العمر 9 سنوات و11
سنه والان يتم عمليه انقاذ لشقيقتهم
الصغرى والبالغه من العمر 7 سنوات على ما
يبدو ان في فرق الانقاذ كانوا يبحثون عن
شخص يتحدث العربيه ليتم التواصل مع الفتاه
والحديث معها من تحت الانقاض
على ما يبدو من يعني جلب اداه استشعار
الصوت
وقبل قليل استخدموا ايضا الكلاب البوليسيه
المدربه فعلى ما يبدو ان هذه العمليه
معقده اكثر مما نتمنى ولكن رغم ذلك الامل
ما زال قائم وندعو الله ان يحفظ هذه
الفتاوى يعني
يجمعها
بشقيقاتها هذه هؤلاء الفتيات الثلاث ام
ضوء سته ايام تحت الانقاض واكثر من
على ما يبدو اننا
فقدنا الاتصال ربما تعود الصوره
المباشره لعمل عمليه الانقاذ التي تقام في
قهرمان مرعش
للفتاه السوريه البالغه من العمر 7 سنوات
والتي ظلت تحت الانقاض لمده سته ايام
مشاهدينا من دون غذاء ولا ماء ولا حتى
تدفئه اذا ما زال هناك امل وما زال هناك
ترقب للحظات فرح
لاخراج هذه الفتوى وانضمامها ولم شملها مع
شقيقاتها في المستشفى الذين ذهبوا قبل
قليل مع خالهم وقد شهدنا ذلك قبل قليل
غسان ما الذي يحدث الان
ما زالت عمليات المناداه نحن نسمع
المنقذين ينادون على
الطفله من تحت الانقاض لكن حتى اللحظه
نعرف بالضبط ما هو الوضع بعد هذه المناداه
حين طلبوا منا لحظات الصمت ننتظر طبعا
يستخدمون الان الجهاز الذي جلبوه قبل قليل
ربما مكانها الان يخرجون الجهاز نعم الان
يخرجون الجهاز
يخرجون الجهاز من داخل
الثغره التي
يوجد بداخلها المنقذ والطفله العالقه
يخرجون الان قطع من الاثاث من الخشب
يخرجون البسه
واضح انهم يعني
من خلال هذه القطع انهم وصلوا لمكان لم
يصلوا من قبل
ويحاولون
الان يستخدمون جهاز اخر على ما اعتقد
كاميرا على ما اعتقد كاميرا لم يعني
نستطيع تحديد ما هو هذا الجهاز بحجم كف
اليد يدخلونه الى داخل الثغره
يبدو ان هذا الشخص لا اعرف هو شخص
عن اي شخص تتحدث غسان بانتظار اي جديد حتى
هذا هل هو من اقارب هذه الطفله احد
المنقذين
يبدو ذلك لكننا حاولنا ان نتواصل معه قبل
قليل لكنه رفض لكن ما نشاهده انه يبكي على
ما اعتقد الان
صمت الان صمت نعم ونحن نحترم ذلك معك غسان
لحظه بلحظه في متابعه عمليه الانقاذ الان
في قهرمان مرعش عبر شاشه العربيه ومع
موفدنا غسان ابو لوز الذي يتابع هذه
العمليه المباشره
لانتشال طفله سوريه تبلغ من العمر 7 سنوات
عالقه تحت الانقاط ولكنها ما زالت على قيد
الحياه وتم تاكيد ذلك عن طريق عن طريق
سماع صوتها وعن طريق الكلاب البوليسيه
المدربه وكذلك عن طريق
شقيقاتها الذين تم اللتين تم انقاذهم قبل
قليل
واسعافهم ونقلهم الى المستشفى القريبه
منهم كان معهم خالهم الذي عاد الى الموقع
ليطمئن على ابنه اخته البالغه من العمر 7
سنوات والعالقه منذ سته ايام
هذا المبنى طبعا هذا المبنى المدمر
بالكامل والذي سوي بالارض اثر مبنى يبلغ
ربما سته سبعه او حتى عشره طوابق لا نعلم
بالتاكيد ولكنه سقط على رؤوسهم ورغم ذلك
هم ما زالوا على قيد الحياه وما زالوا
متمسكين بالامل على ان يخرجوا سالمين من
تحت الانقاض ويتم لم شمل الطفله مع
اخواتها في المستشفى
انتهت لحظات الصمت على ما يبدو غسان
نعم هناك حديث بين عناصر الانقاذ يبدو ان
هذا الشخص باسل لو سمحت هذا الشخص يمسك
بالشاشه او بجهاز يتحكم بالكاميرا التي تم
ادخالها ويبدو انه لانهم يرصدون رصد شيء
ما لا ادري ما هو بالضبط لكنهم ادخلوا
كاميرا الى داخل الثغره ويتحكمون فيها عن
بعد
ويبدو انهم يطلبون الصمت صمت اخر صمت اخرى
نعم اذا لحظات الصمت متكرره
لفرق الانقاذ المتواجدين
في قهرمان مرعش في هذا الحي المدمر
بالكامل كما ذكر لنا موفد العربيه غسان حي
كامل مدمر اثراء الزلزال ولكن ما زالت
عمليات الانقاذ مستمره لاي احياء تحت
الالقاب وبالفعل في الدقائق الاخيره وفي
الساعه الاخيره شاهدنا معكم اخراج شقيقتين
وشاهدنا اخراج ونشهد الان عمليه محاوله
اخراج الشقيقه الثالثه البالغه من العمر 7
سنوات لحظات صمت متكرره لمحاوله سماع صوت
الطفل مجددا ومحاوله تحديد موقعها ايضا من
دون
الحدوث او من دون التسبب باي ضرر لها او
سقوط اي ركان او
منازلهم ولكن يتخوفون من فقدانها اثر
تصدعها يبقون في سياراتهم يبقون في
الحدائق وفي الاماكن المكشوفه خوفا من اي
هزات ارتداديه لانه تم رصد بالفعل اكثر من
1800 هزه ارتداديه حتى الان ومنذ وقوع
الزلزال طبعا الهزات الارتداديه تبلغ
قوتها سبعه او اقل سبعه على مقياس رختر او
اقل فهي تعتبر هزه ارتداديه فبالتالي يمكن
ان تكون بالفعل قويه ويمكن ايضا ان تسبب
باضرار خصوصا في المباني المهترئه المباني
القديمه والمباني المتصدعه اثراء الزلزال
الذي وقع يوم الاثنين بالتالي الناس
يخرجون من هذه المباني خوفا من اي اصابات
ومن اي زلازل قادمه وهذا كان ايضا يعني ما
ناشد به الرئيس التركي ونائب الرئيس ومن
الوزراء المعنيين بان يخرجوا الناس من
المباني المتصدعه ولا يقتربون من المناطق
المنكوبه خوفا من سقوط اي مباني عليهم اذا
يبدو ان لحظه الصمت انتهت
لحظه الصمت انتهت الجهاز نعم صحيح الجهاز
الذي كان يستخدمه الان هو عباره عن كاميرا
حراريه ادخلها
احد المنقذين يشير لنا بان الوضع يعني ان
شاء الله وضعها جيد الطفله الشخص المسؤول
عن الكاميرا الحراريه يشير او ماء براسه
بان ان شاء الله بان وضعها جيد فاطمه ما
تشاهدينه الان نحن لنا اكثر من ساعه نحاول
يعني رصد لحظه اخراج الطفله تمام فهي
تختصر تختصر مدى معاناه فرق الانقاذ في
الوصول الى العالقين وبالتالي نعم
ونحن معك اذا تم استخدام ادوات استشعار
صوتيه وتم استخدام
كاميرا وادخالها الى هذه الثغره تحت
الركام لمحاوله الاطمئنان على الطفله وعلى
ما يبدو من ردود فعل المنقبين بان الطفله
بخير وعلى قيد الحياه
ويحاولون الوصول اليها
لموقعها تحديدا تحت الركام ويتم بعد ذلك
انقاذها وانتشالها لحظات صمت متكرره
نشاهدها معكم لهذه العمليه عمليه الانقاذ
لحظات الصمت هي من يعني الطرق المتبعه
لفرق الانقاذ هناك لمحاوله سماع ما يمكن
سماعه لمحاوله الوصول لمن هم تحت الانقاض
احياء يبدو ان فرق الانقاذ يشيرون لاداء
يريدون اداء معينه لتسهيل
هذه العمليه لهم شاهدناهم يستخدمون مطرقه
وسكين استخدموا الكلاب البوليسيه
واستخدموا كذلك اجهزه استشعار صوتيه
وكاميرا
لرؤيه ما هو تحت الانقاض ومحاوله العثور
على مكان وتحديد مكان الفتاه
تحت الانقاب طبعا الاليات الثقيله يتم
استخدامها في البدايه ولكن يصلون الى
مرحله يتم التوقف والامتناع عن استخدام
اليات ثقيله حتى لا يسببون او يتسببون باي
اضرار لاي احياء كانوا متواجدين تحت
الاوقات فهذه المرحله تحديدا التي نشاهدها
يستخدمون ادوات بدائيه
ليتمكنوا من الحفر ومن ازاله الرسام ومن
الوصول الى الفتاه الطفله البالغه من
العمر 7 سنوات تحت الانقاض
يبدو انهم ما زالوا يخرجون
يعني ركام من هذه الثغره تحت الانقاض
لمحاوله الوصول للطفله العالقه طبعا
شاهدنا قبل قليل رجل وهو يبكي حول هذه
الانقاض على ما يبدو انه له علاقه بالطفله
بالتاكيد ولكنه رفض بطبيعه الحال التحدث
الان للوضع الذي هم فيه يعني وضع جدا
ماساوي ومؤلم
وخطير ونترقب اي امل لحظات اي فرحه اي
يمكن ان نعيشها معهم في هذه اللحظات
غسان هل انتهت لحظه الصمت
يبدو ذلك فاطمه يبدو ذلك هم يطلبون المزيد
من الادوات المعدات لكن لا نستطيع تحديد
ما هي موجوده في حقيبه الان تحضر حقيبه
سوداء
لكن لا نعرف ما هي بالضبط
وكما كنا نقول فاطمه يعني ما نشاهده الان
ما نشاهده الان منذ اكثر من ساعه يؤشر
بشكل واضح مدى تعقيد عمليات الانقاذ
وبالتالي
يؤشر بشكل واضح كيف يتعاملون مع هذه
الحالات من الانقاذ ومحاوله انتشال
الناجين من تحت الانقاض نظرا
خطورتها عوده الالات الثقيله يعني نبدا
يبدو اننا نرى طرف اليا ثقيله هل
سيستخدمونها ام انها هناك
مستحيل يستخدمونها فاطمه هذه اليه موجوده
منذ ان وصلنا لكنها متوقفه بهذا الشكل على
هذا الحال يعني فهي موجوده منذ ان وصلنا
لكن الان يستخدمون ادوات اخرى يدخل منقذ
ويخرج اخر يستخدمون المطارق والمعاون
والزميل
ويخرجون الانقاذ
وكنا نقول اننا ن منذ اكثر من ساعه اكثر
من ساعه ننتظر اخراج الشقيقه الثالثه لكن
حتى اللحظه حتى اللحظه
لم يتمكنوا من اخراجها وهذا ما يشير الى
مدى تعقيد عمليات الانقاذ واخراج
الان يستخدمون مترا يعني يستخدمون مترا
لقياس على ما يبدو لقياس المسافه التي
يعني تقع فيها
الطفله ويبدو انها مسافه يعني تصل لنحو
مترين حسب حسب يعني ما شاهدته تقديريا
يعني الان يعود للقياس المنقذ العود يعود
لقياس المسافه وعلى ما يبدو وعلى ما يبدو
على ما اعتقد حسب ما يعني
اراه الان انهم سيحاولون الوصول لها من
منطقه اخرى لكن حتى اللحظه لا شيء اكيد هم
يحاولون القياس من الاسفل ليقدروا
من الاعلى من الاعلى
من الاعلى يعني كما تشاهدين باسل لو سمحت
فقط ارينا المنقذين فوق الانقاذ هل
تشاهدين اين يقف هؤلاء لم اعتقد من هناك
لا ادري يعني بالضبط ان كانوا سيتمكنوا من
الدخول من تلك المنطقه اذا كنت تشاهدين
المتر الان يستخدمينه يستخدمونه القياس
ليحاولوا تحديد موقعها بالضبط
باسل فقط لو تظهر لنا القياس الذي يقومون
به الان نعم نرى غسان
نعم فهم يقيسون من الاسفل المسافه ومن ثم
يقصون من الاعلى
لمحاوله يعني ايجاد نقطه تقديريه اقرب
نقطه يمكن الوصول اليها من الاعلى وعلى ما
يبدو ان تلك النقطه التي اتجهوا اليها
الان من الاعلى اسهل في الوصول
الى الطفله من الاسفل يبدو ان الوضع معقد
جدا في الاسفل ولا يستطيعون الوصول اليها
من الاسفل والان بداوا بالحفر
وازاله الركام من الاعلى
ويحاولون الان واضح انهم يحاولون الان
العمل من جهتين من الجهه العليا ومن الجهه
السفليه من داخل هذه الثغره ومن الجهه
العليا يحاولون العمل الان
لمحاوله الوصول الى محاوله الوصول الى
الطفله العالقه حتى هذه اللحظه
وهم يعملون على جهتين لكسب الوقت فاطمه
لكسب الوقت ان العدو الاول والاخير في هذه
الكارثه هو الوقت الوقت هو العدو الاول
والاخير لفرق الانقاذ وايضا للعالقين
الناجين تحت الانقاض وبالتالي هم قاموا
بقياس المسافه الموجوده من الاسفل ثم
قدروها تقديريا من الاعلى ليبداوا الحفر
الان تدخل اليه يعني متوسطه
واله حفر متوسطه لاستخدامها في عمليه
الحفر من الاعلى في محاوله الوصول فاطمه
الى الطفله من الاعلى ايضا يحاولون كسب
الوقت العمل من جهتين لمحاوله لمحاوله
اخراج نعم محاوله اخراج الفتاه في اسرع
وقت هذا هو المشهد فاطمه في عموم المناطق
التي ضربها الزلزال كما تشاهدين الان هناك
التين هناك التان
ثقلتان يتم استخدامها يتم استخدامها
للاصراع في عمليات ازاله الانقاذ لكن
نتمنى ان يتمكنوا من الازاله بشكل سريع في
نفس الوقت هم يتعاملون بحذر وبحساسيه
الطفله الان باتت اسفلهم يحولون من الاسفل
ومن الاعلى فاي حركه خاطئه فاطمه ممكن ان
تؤثر على
نعم نعم يعني يحاولون الان من الاعلى هناك
يعني عدد من المنقذين يقومون بازاله
الانقاض بالايدي والان يحاولون ايصال
التيار الكهربائي
لاليات المتوسطه للعمل بالبدء او بالحفر
بواسطتها ومن ثم سيحولون الدخول اليها اما
من الاسفل او اما من الاعلى من يصل اولا
ينقذ هذه الفتاه هذا المشهد فاطمه الذي
تشاهدونه هو جزء من مشهد كبير وضخم ممتد
على طول الولايات العشر التي ضربها
الزلزال هذا المشهد وهذه الساعات التي يمر
فيها المنقذون والاهالي والناجين حتى
العالقين ساعات عصيبه هي ساعات يعني مهلكه
للاعصاب ومهلكه جسديا ومهلكه عصبيا ومهلكه
بجميع المقاييس فاطمه
الانقاض غسان يعني راينا معك قبل قليل
استفصاحهم في المنطقه السفليه استخدموا
جهاز استشعار صوتي استخدموا الكاميرا
الكلاب البوليسيه واستخدموا ايضا المتر
لتحديد اماكن او تحديد نقطه تواجد الفتاه
تحديدا تحت الانقاذ ومن ثم انتقلوا لي فوق
الركام ليتمكنوا من ايضا تحديد النقطه
التي تتواجد بها الفتاه بالمتر ويستخدمون
الان اليات متوسطه لتكسير الركام
لازالته والوصول باذن الله الى الفتى حيث
تتواجد تحت الركام يعني قبل قليل ايضا
شاهدنا انقاذ تم انقاذ شقيقتين للفتاه
يبلغان من العمر
11 عاما الفتاه العالقه شقيقتهم الصغرى
تبلغ من العمر 7 سنوات وهم من سوريا كما
علمنا من خاله الذي تواجد في سياره
الاسعاف والتي نقلت السياره الشقيقتين من
هذا المبنى ومن تحت الركام الى المستشفى
ليتم الان فاطمه بداوا عمليات الحفر
بالاليات المتوسطه بداوا عمليات الحفر
بالاليات المتوسطه وبداوا يعملون من
الاعلى في بالتزامن مع العمل من الاسفل من
الثغره التي كنا نراقبها ونتابعها منذ
اكثر من ساعه الان بداوا الان طلبوا توقف
الان طلبوا توقف لحظه صمت من هم بالاسفل
طلبوا من بالاعلى بتوقف بالتوقف عن الحفر
الان
اذا هناك فرق في الاسفل تراقب الوضع هل
هناك في العراق طلبوا منهم ان يتوقفوا
هناك فرق في الاسفل تراقب الوضع هناك فرق
فوق الركام تحاول تكسيره وازالته للوصول
الى الفتاوى يبدو على ما يبدو ان الفرق
المتواجده في الاسفل طلبوا من الفرق فوق
الركام ان يتوقفوا من التكسير واستخدام
الاليات الثقيله في هذه اللحظات كما نشاهد
معكم عبر كاميرا العربيه
[موسيقى]
نعم يعني يعني كنا نقول قبل قليل انهم
يحاولون
مسابقه الزمن للوصول سواء كان من الاسفل
او من الاعلى لكنهم عندما شرعوا في العمل
من الاعلى العناصر التي في الاسفل طلبت
منهم ان يتوقفوا وهذا يؤشر ايضا انهم حين
بداوا في العمل من الاعلى بدا يؤثر على
الوضع في الاسفل لذلك طلبوا منهم ان لا
يستخدموا الاليات الان ينادون بالاصوات لم
اعتقد هم طلبوا لحظه صمت ولا يريدون
بالاصوات اسمع المنقذ الان داخل الثغره
ينادي على الطفله نعم ونحن سنحترم منهم
صوت يمكن ان التحدث الان يعني ابتعد عنهم
قليلا يمكنهم التحدث الان هم يحاولون
تحديد يعني موقع الطفله بالضبط من عن طريق
الصوت
فهذه الحاله تكررت خلال هذه الساعه اكثر
من مره فاطمه لذلك
العمليه تكون معقده جدا حتى بالكاميرات
الحراريه وحتى باجهزه الاستشعار لكن يبدو
ان الوضع في الداخل معقد جدا وبالتالي هم
لا يعلمون اين
يعني بالضبط في اي اتجاه ممكن ان تكون
ويحاولون ان يحددوا هذا المكان حتى يتجهوا
اليها بشكل واضح لا ندري ما هي حقيقه
الامر في داخل هذه الثغره نحاول يعني
قراءه ما يمكن قراءته من خلال المعطيات
التي نشاهدها بالعين المجرده لا يوجد احد
يمكن ان يفسر لنا في هذه اللحظات الصعبه
من المختصين بطبيعه الحال فاطمه لذلك
نحاول ان نقرا هذا المشهد
ونفهم ما الذي يجري على اي حال ما زالت
يعني العمليات متواصله ومستمره حتى هذه
اللحظه هذا هو المشهد يعني جزء من مشهد
كبير في عموم الولايات التي ضربها الزلزال
وكما قلنا بان الوقت هو العدو الاول
والاخير للعالقين وايضا لفرق الانقاذ
لماذا تتاخر عمليات الانقاذ كما نشاهد
الان هذا يعني اكثر شيء ممكن ان يفسر لنا
هذا اكثر شيء ممكن ان يفسر لنا لماذا
تتاخر عمليات الانقاذ كنا نقول في السابق
ان اي عمليه خطا في عمليات الانقاذ ممكن
ان تؤثر سلبا وتكون كارثيه على العالقين
وعلى المنقذين حتى لانهم كما تشاهدون
يدخلون تحت الانقاض فاي عمليه خاطئه ممكن
ان ينهار تنهار الانقاض على المنقذ ايضا
وتكون المشكله يعني
بمضاعفه فلذلك تتم العمليات فاطمه بشكل
دقيق جدا وبشكل
حثيث جدا وبشكل حريص
العمليه ليست سهله شخص ما من المنقلين
طبعا يدخل الى هذه الثغره يعني الى نصف
يبدو ان هدف فاطمه يبدو انه يبدو انه خال
الفتى على ما اعتقد انه خلف فتاه لم اتمكن
من مشاهده وجهه لكن حسب ما فهمت انه خال
الفتاه يحاول المنادى عليها على ما اعتقد
انها لا تفهم التركيه وبالتالي لا تتجاوب
او انها خائفه
بالضبط ما هو الوضع في الداخل فاطمه يعني
الوضع سريالي في الداخل الوضع لا يمكن
تصوره في الداخل وبالتالي نحن نحاول قراءه
ما يمكن قراءته من المعطيات التي نشاهدها
بالعين المجرده الوضع صعب جدا يحاول على
ما اعتقد خالها ان ينادي عليها
يمكن ان تصدر اي صوت حتى يتمكنوا من
تحديدها وبطبيعه الحال حين تصدر اصوات او
تنادي كما حدث في حالات سابقه يمكن تحديد
موقع بالضبط ممكن التوجه او التعامل معها
يعني
بزوايا اخرى من هذه الثغرات لا نعلم
بالضبط ما الذي يجري الان يخرج على ما
يبدو
او يبدو انه
او ما يبدو اعتقد هذا خلها الثاني على ما
اعتقد خالها الثاني الذي رفض الحديث معنا
والذي اشرنا قبل قليل انه كان يبكي على ما
اعتقد ان خالها الثاني خالها الاول الذي
اجرنا مقابله معه ذهب مع
الشقيقتان الى المستشفى ولم يعد الى
الموقع دخلوها الثاني يجلس هنا
لا لم نشاهده حتى هذه اللحظه
وعلى ما اعتقد ان هذا هو خالها الثاني او
ربما يعني احد اقاربها لا ندري بالضبط
الان بداوا الحفر فاطمه من الاعلى بداوا
يحفرون من الاعلى باستخدام المعد نعم
باستخدام المعدات
المتوسطه المعدات الثقيله المتوسطه الان
عمليات الحفر تبدا من الاعلى في المقابل
المنقذين من الاسفل ما زالوا يعملون في
محاوله للوصول الى هذه الطفله نتحدث عن لا
ادري كم يعني الان مضى من الوقت ونحن نقف
في هذا المكان وهم يحاولون انتشالها نتحدث
عن ساعه او اكثر من ساعه ربما لكن لا تنسي
فاطمه انهم كانوا لكن لا تنسي فاطمه انهم
كانوا يعملون قبل لا نصل احنا نحن يعني
الى هذا الموقع فلك ان تتخيل لعدد الساعات
نحن نتحدث عن اليوم السادس
نتحدث الان عن قبل اكثر من ساعه اخراج
دقيقتين من تحت الانقاب نتحدث عن شقيقه
ثالثه ما زالت تحت الانقاض وما زالوا
يحاولون الوصول اليها وصلوا الى اثنتين
الان يحاولون الوصول الى الثالثه لنا اكثر
من ساعه نتابع ونرصد هذه اللحظات وما زالت
العمليات مستمره الان يطلبون من العناصر
في الاعلى ان يتوقفوا عن الحفر
الان الفرق في اسفل طلبت مجددا من الفرق
في الاعلى ان تتوقف عن الحفر وما زال
المنقذون يعني في الاسفل ايضا
يعملون حتى هذه اللحظه
يخرجون الانقاذ حتى هذه اللحظه هذا هو
المشهد فاطمه هذا هو المشهد المعقد الذي
تواجهه فرق الانقاذ في
المناطق المنكوبه في جنوب البلاد تعامل
يعني كانهم يسيرون في حق الالغام وربما
اكثر من الالغام الوضع خطير جدا اي حركه
محسوبه اي اي حجر ممكن ان يحركوه ممكن ان
يؤدي الى كارثه وبالتالي تاخذ هذا الوقت
الطويل من العمل
وهذا النفس الطويل من العمل وهذا الصبر
الطويل من العمل لذلك تتاخر قليله
العمليات الانقاذ وتاتي تتوالى الانباء عن
انقاذ شخص هنا وشخص هناك بين ساعه واخرى
الاف العمال عشرات الالاف من عمال الانقاذ
الذين يعملون الان ويتواصلون ويتواصلون
عملهم حتى هذه اللحظه محاوله فوق
لشيء ما ربما بدا الحفر عاد الحفر
عاد الحفر لا ادري ما الذي يطلبونهم
يتحدثون التركيه لكنهم
ابعدون عن
لا ادري ما الذي يريدونه بالضبط لكن على
ايه حال
تتواصل عمليه الحفر الان من الاعلى عادت
يواصلون الحفر من الاسفل يزيلون العقاب
بالايدي التي يتم استخدامها في حفر الركام
وتكسير الحطام للوصول الى الفتاه اذا
استمرت ولم لم يطلب منهم ان يتوقفوا حتى
اللحظه مما ربما ربما يشير الى انهم
توصلوا الى اليه ربما صحيحه وامنه للوصول
للفتاه ميلنا ذلك
وهذا ما يعني ينتظره الكل هنا ان شاء الله
لنتمكنوا من الوصول الى الفتاوى وانتشالها
بخير وكما شاهدنا قبل قليل في الساعه
الماضيه
هذه اللحظات العقيده مازال
لاستخراج شقيقتين من تحت الانقاض تم نقلهم
بالاسعاف في الساعه الماضيه والان يتم
محاوله العثور على شقيقتهم الثالثه
والصغرى والتي تبلغ من العمر 7 سنوات
فرق الانقاذ يحاولون اتباع خطط مختلفه
يعني رايناهم يحاولنا يحاولون الدخول من
احدث ثغرات الموجوده في الحطام ولكنهم لما
يتمكنوا بالتالي استخدموا متر لمقياس
مسافه الفتاه واليات لسماع صوتها للتاكد
من انها على قيد الحياه وبالفعل تاكدوا من
ذلك ثم انتقلوا الى فوق الحطام وفوق
الركام وايضا استخدموا المتر ليقيسوا ربما
عمق تواجد الفتاوى مسافه تواجدها
ويستخدمون الان الاليات الثقيله لمحاوله
تكسير
الحطام ولكن يعني هذه المرحله ليست
بالهينه كما ذكر غسان يعني مرحله حرجه جدا
وليست بالهينه ومعقده لان اي غلطه صغيره
قد تؤدي لا سمح الله الى سقوط الركام او
مزيد من الركام على الفتاوى يعني عرقله
عمليه الانقاذ هذه ولكن لا نامل حدود ذلك
ونامل استخراج الفتاه وهي معافاه وعلى قيد
الحياه وبصحه وان يتم لم شملها مع
شقيقاتها المتواجدات في المستشفى القريب
من هذه المنطقه في قهرمان مرعش في تركيا
يبدو ان هناك اليه اخرى يبدو انهم يحضرون
اليه هذه الاليه على ما اعتقد
لقطع الحديد القضبان الحديديه هذه الاليه
التي يحملها هذا الشخص
لا لا هذا هذه لقطع هذه القضبان عفوا التي
كانت عالقه في الاليه الكبيره وليست
للفتاه يعني
هنا
نتوقع ان يكون لعمليه انقاذ الفتاه نظرا
للظروف الصعبه التي
لابد انها مرتبطه غسان يعني ربما مستمره
كثفوا الان كثفوا الان فاطمه كثفوا عمليات
الحفر من الاعلى بقي شخص واحد منقذ في
الاسفل وعمليات الحفر من الاعلى الان
تتكثف بشكل كبير وعلى ما يبدو ان حسب
تقديراتهم بان
الحفر من الاعلى هو اسهل للوصول الى هذه
الفتاه ما زال احد الاشخاص ما زال في
الاسفل ويحاول ازاله هذه الانقاذ كل
العناصر وكل فرق الانقاذ اتجهت الى الاعلى
والان يقومون بتحطيم الركام باستخدام
الاليات المتوسطه
من الاعلى على امل الوصول اليها طبعا هم
يعملون في هذه النقطه تحديدا فاطمه بعدما
قاموا بتحديد بعدما قاموا بتحديدها
بتحديدها بالمتر وقياسها بالمتر نلاحظ
الان فاطمه ان الاليه الكبيره الضخمه تلتف
الى الجهه الاخرى التي يعملون فيها من
الاعلى على ما يبدو على ما يبدو نحن نتابع
حتى اللحظه انها قد تتدخل لازاله الحطام
الكبير الضخم الذين لا يستطيعون التعامل
معه وفسح المجال امال امام العناصر
البشريه نعم نعم هم يعني على ما اعتقد
انهم
توقفت الاليه توقفت الاليه لا ندري بالضبط
عفوا ما الذي لماذا اتت الى هنا لكن لكنها
بالتاكيد اقتربت الى الموقع موقع تواجد
الفتى ربما يعني ان تكون قريبه في حال
احتاجها
غيرت موقعها نعم صحيح
ربما يحتاجونها لاحقا لكن العمليات الان
باتت من الاعلى بشكل كامل
توقفت من الاسفل وباتت من الاعلى طبعا كما
قلنا انهم قاموا بقياس
بواسطه متر
وتقديراتهم اشارت الى ان هذه المسافه وهذه
النقطه تحديدا هي التي
تقع اسفلها الفتاه وبداوا الحفر الان
بالمعدات الثقيله المتوسطه باتجاه الفتى
ويحاولون الان تكسير هذا الحطام
بالتين
[موسيقى]
في محاوله فكفكه
الان يشير لي
نعم الان يشير لاحد المنقذين انهم يعني
حددوا مكانها بالضبط
اين هي بالضبط
ويحاولون الوصول اليها من الاعلى وعلى ما
يبدو انهم يعني متاكدون تماما بانها او
بان الطريقه الاخرى او المكان الاخر الذين
يحفرون منه سيكون اسهل عليهم للوصول الى
الفتاه ربما من خلال عمليات رصدهم من داخل
هذه الثغره بواسطه الكاميرات الحراريه
وبواسطه العناصر البشريه التي تمكنت من
الوصول يعني قيمت بان الدخول من الاعلى
اسهل من الاسفل لا نعلم ما هي حقيقه الوضع
بالداخل ربما هناك المزيد من الحطام او
حتى القضبان الحديديه والمساحه ضيقه جدا
لا تسمح بتحرك العناصر البشريه بشكل جيد
لذلك لجاوا الى الدخول الى او محاوله
الدخول من الاعلى فاطمه لا ادري انقطع
الاتصال لا ادري ان كنتم نحن معك غسان
ونسمعك وصوره واضحه جدا
نتابع الان عمليه انقاذ طفله تبلغ من
العمر سبع سنوات كانت عالقه هي وشقيقاتها
الاخريتين
تبلغان من العمر 11 عاما وتسعه اعوام تم
انقاذ هاتين الشقيقتين
ونقلهما الى
ونقلهما الى المستشفى لتلقي العلاج اللازم
الان ما زلنا ننتظر
بننتظر اخراج الطفله الثالثه من تحت
الانقاذ في هذه الساعات طبعا نحن نقف هنا
منذ اكثر من ساعه وما زالت عمليات الانقاذ
مستمره طبعا انتشلوا الشقيقتان من هذه
الثغره لا ادري ان كنتم تشاهدونها
انتشلوها من هذه الثغره لكنهم لم يتمكنوا
من انتشال الشقيقه الثالثه وبالتالي الى
ذاتها التي كنا يعني كانوا يعملون بها قبل
قليل صحيح
ده انت شو بتقربلها
طيب خلينا ناخذك على الهواء خليك معي بس
بدهم يشبكوني لانه فصل نزل الماسك ولا
بدكش ما بدي الو
هل احد يسمعني نعم نسمعك غسان
فاطمه اعتقد انه هناك احد الاشخاص نتعرف
عليك لو سمحت
بتكون بنت بنت عمي البنت
عمرها سبع سنوات
ما دخلت الروضه جدا هلا عم بشوف التلفزيون
الله يجزيكم الخير وبطلب من كل اللي عم
تشوفونا يدعينا سوره ياسين سوره ايه
الكرسي عليك الله يخرجها بخير وسلامة
ليش غيروا موقع البنت محصوره انه محصوره
بمنطقه ضيقه كتير ما بحسن حتى اختها طلعت
من شوي انه اخطر عايشه كيف وضعهم
الصحيّ بس هاي بنت صغيره كتير من الساحه
عربي
وممكن بعد ما حكيت الله اعلم انه اغمى
عليها ممكن يكون
لكن اكدوا لكم انه وضعها جيد واخواتها في
المستشفى اكدوا لكم انه وضعها جيد الحمد
لله ما فيها اصابات ولا الحمد لله رب
العالمين بسمع الاسف
يعني كانوا على قيد الحياه في الامس
وتوفوا ولا توفوا كانوا متوفين شفناهم
متوفين ابوهم وامهم واختهم صغيره يعني
عائله مكونه من ست اشخاص ثلاثه توفوا الاب
والام
حاليا والله الثالثه موجوده تحت الارقام
اب وام
ولد ام بنت اللي كلهم بنات كلهم
اين مقيم جدهم جدهم نحن مقيمين حاليا مقيم
حوالي مارسين في طرطوس نجحنا بسبب الاوضاع
العشيره في الزلزال
انتم كيف وضعكم كمان انتم
الحمد لله رب العالمين الحمد لله
ولكن على وشك التهدم يعني هو قايل للسقوط
وبالتالي طلبت منك السلطات الخروج طيب وين
رحتوا كيف عايشين
يعني المخيمات وناس لجات الى اقارب اخر
كيف وضعكم الحمد لله الحمد لله والله
بحاجه كل شيء
بحاجه الدعاء الله تنقصكم مساعدات هل هناك
نقص في المساعده في مساعده بس والله نحن
ما عم نبحث عن المساعدات بس بدنا الدعاء
بس بدنا نعيش بخير وسلامه
ان شاء الله ان شاء الله ان شاء الله الله
يفرجها كما استمعت فاطمه هذا احد اقارب
هذه الطفله اكد لنا بان الطفله بخير وبصحه
جيده بحسب الشقيقاتها في المستشفى التي
اكدنا
كانها بصحه جيده لكن كما قال كما قال بان
الطفله حسب ما ابلغهم عناصر الانقاذ ان
الطفله محصوره في زاويه صعب الوصول اليها
من الاسفل وبالتالي لجاوا الى
الحفر من الاعلى ربما تكون اسهل حسب
المعلومات المتوفره حتى الان من اقارب
الطفله نقلا عن عناصر الانقاذ ونقلا عن
شقيقاتها التي تم اسعافهن وهن بصحه جيده
كما ابلغنا
احد اقاربهن بانها بان الطفل العالقه التي
ما زالت عالقه والتي تبلغ من العمر سبع
سنوات بصحه جيده لكنها ما زالت محصوره في
زاويه صعب الوصول اليها من هذه الثغره
وبالتالي قاموا بالعمل من الاعلى وكما
علمنا بانها هي اسره كامله مكونه من سته
اشخاص توفي الاب والام
والشقيقه الرابعه توفيت بقي بقي ثلاث
شقيقات على قيد الحياه
اخرج شقيقه وبقيت واحده عمرها سبع سنوات
حتى الان تحت الانقاض محصوره في زاويه
صعبه على المنقذين ان يصلون اليها
وبالتالي لجاوا الى الحفر من الاعلى
لمحاوله الوصول الى الفتاه طبعا بعدما
قاموا بادخال اجهزه استشعار وكاميرات
حراريه قاموا بقياس المنطقه بالمتر وقاموا
بتقديرها تقديريا من الاعلى ثم بداوا
بالحفر اسفل هذه
الى الاسفل وتكسير هذه الانقاض في محاوله
الوصول الى الفتاوى نتمنى ان تخرج بخير
هذه الفتاه على ايه حال والمهم في هذه
اللحظه فاطمه بان الطفله بصحه جيده بحسب
شقيقات الطفل التي خرجنا قبل ساعه او اكثر
من ساعه من الان خرجنا وهنا الان في
المستشفى واكدنا بانها بصحه جيده يعني
لسنا هن في وضع صحي سيء او انها ليست في
وضع صحيا سيء
وهذا يساعد يعني مقاومه الطفله لهذه
الظروف الصعبه لانها لو كانت مصابه قد
يكون الامر خطير جدا وقد تكون كل دقيقه في
هذه اللحظه فاطمه
وبالتالي
الطفله كما فهمنا انها بصحه جيده والحمد
لله طبعا كما استمع
انه
نراقب معك ونتابع معك غسان لحظه بلحظه
عمليه الانقاذ هذه المباشره عبر كاميرا
العربيه وبطبيعه الحال بسبب الاوضاع هناك
يكون هناك تقطيع ربما في الصوره والصوت
ولكننا نكمل معك ونبقى معك لحظه بلحظه